Hallo Leute, ich dachte mir, so für die ersten zwei Minuten, ich weiß nicht wie lange der Song ist, brauchen wir mal ein bisschen Headbanger-Musik.
Und das Schöne ist, dass es keine MonkaTOS-Musik, weil die aus dem Game-Soundtrack ist.
Metal Hellsinger, Official Game-Soundtrack.
Any GP Morgan Love Runners hier im Chat?
Wobei, nee, das ist ja gerade erst.
Heute ist so ein komischer Lauf in Frankfurt, wo alle im Bahnhofsviertel mitmachen.
Also Unternehmen, ich laufe da nicht mit.
Aber viele, ich glaube, die haben bis zu 50.000 Leute oder sowas haben die da erwarten, so heute im Bahnhofsviertel.
Korrekt.
Ich war ja sogar schon draußen.
Ich bin abgehauen auf der Arbeit, bevor die alles gesperrt haben.
Ich habe heute, wo ich euch meinte, erzähle ich euch gleich.
Ja, Reddit ist so im Streik so halb, ne.
MonkaS.
Ich würde sagen, ich bin mehr ausgelastet jetzt als auf der alten Arbeit.
Weil auf der alten Arbeit habe ich ja auch ein bisschen die letzten paar Monate echt so krass mein Leben gechillt, wie man das so schön nennt heutzutage.
Ihr habt es gleich geschafft, Leute.
Noch zwei Minuten.
Das ist eine gute Frage, fällt mir jetzt auch nichts zu ein.
Aber ich wollte euch gleich was erzählen.
Weniger Stress.
Hörst du Musik? Ja.
Wobei ich sonst eher Power Metal höre.
Aber das bietet sich an, weil das keine MonkaToss Musik ist.
Aber sowas höre ich auch.
Ich höre auch übelstes Wikinger Heavy Metal mit Gekrolle und Gekrunze und so.
Aber hauptsächlich Power Metal.
Was macht dein Auto?
Tja, was macht so ein Auto? Das fährt.
Und funktioniert noch alles.
Ihr habt es gleich geschafft, Leute.
Ja gut, wenn irgendjemand einen Power Metal Song kennt, dann ist es ja...
Dann ist es das...
Oder...
Das dürfte somit das bekannteste sein.
Ich meine, Painkiller sind die Leute zu jung heute.
Ich glaube, Through the Fire and Flames könnte wirklich eines der bekanntesten Power Metal Songs überhaupt sein.
Ich glaube, das ist es.
Wie geht es der Heizung? Die heizt immer noch und kostet ganz schön viel Geld.
Und jetzt erst mal Kontrastprogramm, Leute.
Warum ist das so laut auf einmal?
Das ist lauter als das andere.
Ich überlege gerade, was ist der bekannteste...
Okay, Moment.
Das suche ich jetzt mal.
Was ist das bekannteste...
Bekannteste...
Most Famous Power Metal Song.
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Best Power Metal Songs Top 10 List.
Ja, Moment. Das sind nicht automatisch die bekanntesten.
Okay, das ist wirklich nice.
Also, die ganzen Blind Guardian Sachen aus der Zeit sind extrem pogge.
Der ist es auch nice. Das tatsächlich.
Also, gerade die ersten zwei Alben von dem sind wirklich nice.
Ja, okay.
Weil man auf italienisches...
Ja, das ist auch nicht so durchaus okay.
To the Fire and Flames, was sonst?
Das auch nice.
Okay, das ist natürlich ewig. Das geht zwölf Minuten oder so.
Uralt. Das ist wahrscheinlich bevor ich geboren wurde.
Das ist auch mega nice.
Sehr viel Blind Guardian würde ich auch so unterschreiben.
Eines der besten Power Metal Bands ever.
Leider sind die neuen Sachen nicht mehr so geil.
Okay, Sabaton ist nicht so meins irgendwie.
Zwar mit eines der bekanntesten Bands in dieser Richtung.
Das mag ich aber nicht so.
Okay, okay.
Powerwolf, auch nice.
Na, der Rest ist jetzt eher random, oder?
Übrigens, wer auf Power Metal steht.
Leute.
Glory Hammer hat ein neues Album.
Wer sowas mag.
Das da.
Ich find's nice.
Trotz neuem Sänger.
Ein paar Sachen denke ich mir gut.
Hat man schon so und so gehört.
Aber zum größten Teil sehr nice.
Nächsten Monat Informatikor Studiumprüfung.
Eats.
Ach, da fällt mir ein zum Thema Prüfung.
Ich hab vorhin gesehen, dass...
Ich glaub, das hab ich sogar schon aufgemacht.
Müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken, ob er die Prüfung bestanden hat.
Hier.
Von Technikkeller haben wir doch letztens das Video geguckt
zur Abschlussprüfung, zur IHK-Abschlussprüfung.
Und anscheinend hat er die Prüfung soweit bestanden.
Sonst hätte er jetzt anscheinend nicht die mündliche Prüfung gemacht.
Bin mal gespannt, ob er es insgesamt geschafft hat.
Ich denk mal schon, sonst würde er kein Video machen.
Gucken wir uns aber nachher gleich an.
Alter.
Ich krieg in letzter Zeit, ohne Mist,
ich krieg total viele dieser Beef-Videos empfohlen.
Mich interessiert das so überhaupt nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht,
aber mir geht das so am Arsch vorbei.
Shurioka-Beef mit MontanaBlack mit KuchenTV.
Dann sollen mehr Reakte drauf, ob die sich irgendwie verklagen würden.
Mir geht es legit so krass am Arsch vorbei.
Ich kann es nicht in Worte fassen, wie sehr mir das am Arsch vorbei geht.
Aber ich krieg das auf meiner Startzeit überall.
Also YouTube ist wirklich richtig scharf drauf, dass ich das gucke.
Und wenn du eingeloggt bist, kannst du YouTube ja sagen,
interessiert mich nicht.
Geht aber nicht, wenn du hier nicht eingeloggt bist.
Was ich immer mache jetzt, wenn ich den Scheiß nicht sehen will,
ist anklicken und sofort wieder aus.
Und dann merkt sich YouTube das,
weil deine Playtime so ultra niedrig ist.
Und dann kriegst du so ein Kram nicht mehr empfohlen.
Guck, schon ist es weg.
Aber diese Beef-Dinger, Alter, meine Güte, ey.
Dann verklagen sie sich untereinander.
Boah, jetzt ist alles echt.
Mehr Pepega geht wirklich nicht mehr.
Und dann kommt die eine Community.
Kann man das überhaupt Community nennen?
Da kommen die einen Fanboys an
und regen sich bei den anderen drüber auf
und hateraiden den Twitch-Chat.
Alter, das ist echt nicht mehr normal, was da abgeht.
Tabs? Naja.
Tabs?
Und Tabs?
Guck mal, Virus, guck mal, guck mal.
Ich habe 64 GB RAM.
Und davon benutze ich 9.
Was soll ich mit dem RAM sonst machen, außer 4Ms laufen lassen?
Also irgendwo, ich meine, irgendwo muss das Geld hin.
Manche Leute haben das, stimmt wohl.
Ich hoffe, du bist in 3 Jahren noch aktiv,
damit ich meinen Bachelor abschließen kann.
Du kannst davon ausgehen, dass ich in 3 Jahren noch aktiv bin.
Ohne Mist, Leute, da könnt ihr euch sehr wahrscheinlich,
ich meine, ich weiß nie, was ist.
Könnte sein, dass jetzt hier irgendwie die Rakete einschlägt
und mein Haus in die Luft sprengt oder so.
Ja, oder sonst was.
Aber es ist sehr wahrscheinlich.
Ich meine, ich bin jetzt seit Ende 2010,
da sind fast 13 Jahre aktiv, mehr oder weniger aktiv.
Ja, also ich meine, ich lade 2 Videos am Tag,
Zeit hoch, war ja nur die ersten 2 Jahre oder so.
Aber ich, also ich habe nicht vor,
jemals mit YouTube und Streaming,
ich meine, es ist jetzt ja auch nicht so,
als wäre das mega Belastung.
Ich mache das ja zum größten Teil,
weil es mir Bock macht.
Und irgendwie mal ein Video in der Woche
oder alle 2 Wochen ein Video plus ab und zu mal streamen,
das ist für mich keine Arbeit.
Also ich habe nicht vor, damit aufzuhören.
Alternativ, ich meine, man weiß ja nie, was ist.
Ja, man kann jetzt nie sagen,
na ja, in 10 Jahren bin ich noch da,
aber ich kann euch sagen,
ich habe keinerlei irgendwie da Pläne,
das nicht zu machen.
Und bei mir ist halt das Gute,
ich muss das nicht machen.
Ich verdiene so,
also ich bin nicht auf Content Creation angewiesen.
Ich kann komplett drauf scheißen.
Ich mache zwar ab und zu mal irgendwelche kleinen Sponsorings.
Zum Beispiel, weiß ich nicht,
ob ihr euch noch daran erinnern könnt,
dass ich noch nie in einer Wüste gewesen bin.
Oder, wie war das?
Dieses komische Mobile Matching Game.
Aber ansonsten, das ist echt nur Bonus.
Ich brauche die Kohle nicht.
Und umgedreht ist halt auch das Gute.
Wenn ich jetzt wirklich auf die Arbeit keinen Bock mehr hätte,
was ich nicht habe.
Ich meine, ich bin ja erst seit 2,5 Monaten
jetzt auf der neuen Arbeit.
Da könnte ich auch sagen, weißt du was?
Ich habe genug Kohle und auf der hohen Kante
das Haus hier am Start
und ich kann ein bisschen Content Creating
technisch nebenbei was verdienen.
Das reicht auch erstmal eine Weile
und ich muss mir nicht instant einen neuen Job suchen,
irgendeinen Scheiß, den ich nicht machen will.
Das freut mich zu hören.
Ich weiß immer nicht, was ich da drauf sagen soll.
Ich weiß, es haben viele Leute geschrieben,
so nach dem Motto, Max,
ich habe mich nur beworben damals,
weil du da ein Video zugemacht hast.
Das war nie meine...
Also muss ich sagen, es ist nicht so,
als war ich damals schon so high IQ
und hätte das alles voraus...
gedacht.
Ich habe die Videos einfach gemacht,
weil ich mir dachte,
vielleicht interessiert das den einen oder anderen.
Vor allem halt auch,
weil ich da ein bisschen Content machen konnte.
Ich habe nie daran gedacht,
das ist nicht mein Plan,
aber es freut mich
und ich habe das auch schon von vielen Leuten
hier im Stream gehört,
auch in Kommentaren und so gelesen,
teilweise auch auf Twitter,
die das geschrieben haben.
Ich habe hier vor einem Jahr nach Hilfe erkundigt
beim Ausbildung suchen,
danach Nachhilfe,
was man machen kann,
wenn man rausfliegt.
Da kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern,
aber gut,
ich bekomme viele Messages.
Wenn man rausfliegt,
das...
weiß ich nicht mehr.
Hilfe, was man...
Was macht man denn, wenn man rausfliegt?
Bist du rausgeflogen?
Naja, ich sitze im ersten Stock gerade.
Aus der Ausbildung.
Ja gut, aber anscheinend hast du jetzt ja,
da hast du doch noch was auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Das ist Pog.
Ich sitze im ersten Stock,
also Rakete würde mir schon was ausmachen.
Das ist auch ganz schön,
ganz schön Ressourcenverschwendung.
Der Unterschied zwischen RAM und CPU ist aber,
CPUs kosten nicht bei der Anschaffung Geld,
sondern beim Auslasten Stromkosten aktuell.
Und RAM kostet bei der Anschaffung Geld.
Der Stromverbrauch beim RAM ist egal.
Der Stromverbrauch bei der CPU
ist viel teurer als die CPU
wahrscheinlich nach ein paar Jahren.
Oder zumindest zu den nicht unerheblichen Teilen
nochmal oben drauf.
Alles, alles.
Jetzt bist du im Stream am Start.
Was ist denn das hier?
Ein individueller Supporter des Hypetrains.
Ernsthaft?
Ich sehe gar keinen Hypetrain.
Das ist eh ein Scam.
Der Hypetrain.
Direkte Überweisung an Bezos ist raus.
Ah, ich wollte euch was erzählen.
Und zwar, ich war heute am Hauptbahnhof
und da habe ich was gesehen.
Das habe ich so auch noch nicht gesehen.
Und zwar kam mir jemand entgegen
und ja, ich weiß, das hört sich jetzt
extrem übertrieben an.
Und es war vielleicht jetzt auch nicht so,
so extrem wie man sich vorstellt.
Aber ich glaube schon.
Zumindest, der hatte nur einen halben Kopf.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Der hatte, das sah aus,
als ist dem mal so eine Metallkugel,
als ist dem so eine,
als ist dem ungefähr so eine Kegelkugel
große Metallkugel mal auf den Kopf gefallen.
Stecken geblieben.
Und die haben die wieder raus gemacht
und dann einfach nichts gemacht
und es ist wieder zugewachsen.
So sah der Kopf von dem aus.
Der hatte nur einen halben Kopf.
Ganz normal.
Und auf der anderen Seite
war der Kopf einfach zur Hälfte weg.
So wie als hätte er mal so eine halbe,
als hätte er so eine Kegelkugel
drin eingestellt.
Habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Dem hat nichts gefehlt und so.
Der war nicht behindert oder so.
Der lief da ganz normal rum
durch den Hauptbahnhof,
im Rucksack auf.
Ist mir entgegen gekommen.
Also hat keinen Eindruck gemacht,
wie geht denn sowas?
Soraki, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja, ziemlich große Delle aber schon.
Ja, mit Sicherheit.
Gut, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Aber es sah echt,
also hätte ich nicht für möglich gehalten,
dass das geht.
Ne, hätte ich echt nicht gedacht.
Hab ich irgendwas überlesen, Chatgy?
Leon, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich habe es gar nicht gesehen.
Pog.
Das ist sehr...
Mami, Michael hat 50 Billionen,
ist auch am Start.
Wer hätte gedacht,
dass Microsoft seinen Benutzer belauscht?
Nein, das kann auch nicht sein.
Alternative to...
Moment, die machen News?
Die machen auch News?
Okay.
While the feature sounds exciting,
the browser now warns
that it sends...
Ja, okay, aber...
dass sie nicht
On-Device-Enhancements machen,
das ist doch nichts Neues.
Also, das wundert mich jetzt nicht,
dass sie das serverseitig machen.
Also, da würde ich sogar von ausgehen eigentlich.
Naja, gut, man kann sich auch über alles aufregen.
Ja, genau das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht.
Exakt das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht.
Was ist hier?
Weep attack.
Die Frage heute, Chat, ist ja eindeutig,
weeps in
oder weeps out.
Das ist ja eigentlich die eigentliche Frage heute.
Oh, ich muss die Klimaanlage ausmachen,
jetzt wird es ein bisschen kühl hier gerade.
Was habe ich in die eingestellt?
23 Grad.
Ja, wird es hier eh nicht.
Was haben wir denn?
24,5 haben wir gerade.
Ja, das ist okay.
Ja, total übertrieben, ja.
Weiß auch nicht, das ist...
Was ich tatsächlich interessant fand ist,
heute,
ich hatte es ja auch auf Twitter gepostet,
da war eine Alternative.
Mit dem Unterschied, dass das Ding halt aussieht,
als hätte ich das aus dem alten China-Chinesen-Netzteilgehäuse zusammengebaut.
So.
Und wisst ihr, was der Witz daran ist?
Die bewerben das quasi wegen Handelsembargo und sowas,
sie müssen das ja alles selbst bauen.
Und sie sagen,
der erste rein in Russland gebaute PC und sowas,
in Wirklichkeit sind das ganz normale Armkerne
mit Power...
mit PowerVR-Grafikeinheit,
das ist quasi wirklich ein bisschen übertakteter Raspberry Pi 3.
Und das ist überhaupt nichts unabhängig von...
Außerdem müssen die das auch irgendwie produzieren lassen,
weil ich glaube bei TSMC,
weiß nicht, ob die Russen das überhaupt noch produzieren dürfen aktuell.
Also, im Prinzip ist es blödsinnig.
Ich meine, das Ding sieht schon hardcore scheiße aus, mal ernsthaft, ja.
Das sieht wirklich aus, als hätte ich das bei mir in der Garage
aus ein paar alten Metalldingern zusammengeschraubt.
Und das kann jetzt nicht an den Innen...
Also, wisst ihr, so ein Gehäuse zu bauen,
das sollten die eigentlich noch hinbekommen.
Bei den Innereien kann ich es mir noch vorstellen,
das ist ein bisschen schwierig jetzt alles,
aber das Gehäuse, das sieht wirklich absolut nach Billig-Schrott aus.
Das ist locker nur ein Prototyp,
es wäre aber ziemlich blöd, sowas als großen Erfolg und Prototyp vorzustellen.
Also wenn schon, würde ich eher...
Guckt ihr das mal bei Games an,
da sehen die Prototypen teilweise besser aus,
als die echten Games am Ende.
Also, wenn man sowas marketingtechnisch zeigt,
dann sollte das auch was hermachen, sonst ist man ja blöd.
Hast du schon die neue Apple Vision Pro gesehen?
Ja, habe ich.
Ich persönlich weiß ja nicht so genau,
warum die Welt darauf gewartet hat,
aber, und das muss man Fairness halber sagen,
das hat man sich beim iPhone auch gedacht.
Oder auch damals bei den ersten Macs und sowas.
Wer braucht das eigentlich?
Also, nur weil ich mir das jetzt nicht vorstellen kann,
heißt das nicht, dass es nicht total erfolgreich sein könnte.
Dafür ist es zu groß.
Nee, das sind ARM-CPUs da drauf.
Das, was du meinst, sind diese RockCore-Dinger, oder?
Nee, wie heißen die Dinger?
RockCore, oder?
Das, wo ich ja auch hier im Streamer
einen Odroid benutzt habe mit diesen Dingern drauf.
RockChip, genau, sagte RockCore.
Würdest du es dir für 3,5k holen?
Nö, würde ich nicht.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass ich mir das nie holen würde.
Die erste Generation hole ich mir nicht.
Und ich gehe mal auch davon aus,
dass die nächsten Jahre nicht so teuer bleiben wird.
Das ist bestimmt eher was für Leute,
die jetzt sagen, wir entwickeln da ein paar Anwendungen für.
Ich glaube ernst, nicht wirklich,
dass sich diese 3D-Brille an Anwender richtet,
die daheim schon fertig benutzen wollen.
Ich meine, wer heute aktuell 3D-Content gucken möchte,
der hat irgendeine 3D-Brille.
Und die meisten Leute...
Leute, ihr wisst genauso gut wie ich,
was die erfolgreichste Industrie der Welt ist.
Was die erfolgreichste Industrie ist, was VR angeht.
Und wenn ihr es nicht wisst, könnt ihr es euch denken.
Die erfolgreichste Industrie, was VR angeht, ist Pornos.
Wie bei so vielem.
Und da musst du keine 3,5-Werbel-Brille für haben,
für Leute, die sich sowas angucken wollen.
Yep, Glock, genau.
Kann sein, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ich sehe, der Chat kennt sich aus.
Ich glaube, wenn ist das was in ein paar Jahren,
diese Apple VR-Brille.
Das ist nichts, was man sich jetzt als Anwender verkaufen soll.
Es gibt ja noch nichts für,
nichts, was das super auszeichnet und besser macht als alles andere.
Vielleicht gibt es das aber in ein paar Jahren.
Wisst ihr eigentlich was, also meiner Meinung nach,
wisst ihr, was der Punkt schlechthin ist,
warum sich das iPhone durchgesetzt hat?
Oder zumindest eines der ausschlaggebenden Punkte,
warum sich das iPhone durchgesetzt hat damals?
Meiner Ansicht nach.
Und es schmerzt mich das zu sagen,
aber es wird wohl Safari gewesen sein.
Aber nicht, weil es Safari ist, sondern weil es ein Browser ist.
Einen ordentlichen Browser, den wir mobil dabei haben.
Und normale Internetseiten öffnen können.
Normale Internetseiten zu öffnen können.
Alles im Internet, sag mal,
alles in Anführungsstrichen im Internet machen können,
was man so will und das auch von einem Mobilgerät.
Ich glaube, dass der Browser tatsächlich
eines der entscheidenden Verkaufsargumente für das iPhone war,
am Anfang gerade.
Es gab am Anfang noch nicht viele Apps.
Es gab andere Geräte,
die das, was das iPhone gemacht hat, deutlich besser konnten.
Also nicht in Kombination, aber in Einzelpunkten.
Die erste Kamera vom iPhone war nicht sonderlich geil.
Und Apps gab es ja auch kaum, gerade die ersten paar Jahre.
Also ich denke hauptsächlich,
hat sich das iPhone, gerade so die erste Zeit,
tatsächlich das Hauptverkaufsargument war,
ein Browser, der funktioniert.
Ja, das kommt, hey, das kommt alles dabei.
Apple hat ja nicht das erste Smartphone gebaut.
Apple hat, da habe ich letztens übrigens ein gutes Video drüber geguckt,
wo sich auch jemand über die VR-Brille von Apple ausgelassen hat
oder Spatial Computing oder wie auch immer sie es nennen.
Und er hat gesagt,
Ja, das spielt alles rein.
Apple kann halt gut solche Dinger bauen,
obwohl sie nicht die Ersten in dem Bereich sind,
aber die können halt gute Komplettpakete bauen.
Aber letztendlich bringt es ja auch nichts,
wenn du damit nichts machen kannst.
Und das, was wirklich für mich so die Killeranwendung,
zumindest ist das meine Meinung,
gewesen ist auf den iPhones,
auch in Zeiten, wo es noch nicht viele Apps gab,
war ein ordentliches Problem.
Also ich denke,
auf den iPhones,
auch in Zeiten, wo es noch nicht viele Apps gab,
war ein ordentlicher Browser für unterwegs.
Könnte ich machen,
aber so sehr will ich dann auch.
Also das einzige VR-Spiel,
was ich spielen würde,
wäre das Half-Life,
das Half-Life-Game.
Nee, vielleicht,
vielleicht das VR Resident Evil.
Ansonsten, so viel gibt es ja da eigentlich gar nicht.
VR-Chat werde ich bestimmt nicht anfangen.
Ja,
ich glaube,
die waren nicht die ersten mit einem richtigen Full-Touch-Screen,
aber die ersten, wo das getaugt hat vom Konzept her.
Apple war ja immer sowas selten,
die allerersten.
Wir hatten damals auf der Arbeit,
ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die Dinger noch kennt,
Nokia Communicator,
hieß das Ding, 9000,
ich weiß es gar nicht.
Ja, nee, das gab es doch auch noch mit ein bisschen Farbe.
Ja, so ein Ding in der Richtung.
Hatten wir damals,
ich glaube, das war das,
hatten wir damals so 2007 auf der Arbeit.
Die coolen Leute hatten sowas.
Das waren,
das war die Konkurrenz damals zum iPhone.
Das waren die Smartphones, die es damals gegeben hat.
Moment, das kann man sich noch kaufen,
no, kann man nicht.
Krasse, 80 MB.
Yep, Clock gibt es auch.
Moment, Wikipedia hat was.
Okay, wir suchen mal.
Nee, das ist,
so ein Ding,
9300i hatte damals,
sowas hatte, glaube ich,
mein Chef damals.
Mit Farbdisplay,
und es war auf jeden Fall nicht Silber, sondern Schwarz.
Ja, so ein Teil in der Richtung hatte mein Chef damals.
Das weiß ich noch,
das haben damals nur die wichtigen Leute bei uns gekriegt.
Aber sowas hatten wir auf der Arbeit damals.
Ja, und da konntest du auch schon Wikipedia aufmachen.
Es war halt Schrott,
muss man ganz ehrlich sagen.
Das war so ein Ding,
das war halt cool, was es für Funktionen hatte,
aber das war jetzt nichts,
was ich meiner Oma hätte geben können.
Du kannst das iPhone auch nicht,
das hätte ich meiner Oma,
hätte ich das gezeigt,
und die wären mit dem iPhone nach und nach klargekommen,
mit so einem Ding nicht.
Außerdem war das halt auch ultra fummelig,
und hakelig,
und das war ja Crap, Alter.
Naja, nee,
das Coole damals,
dass dieses riesige,
wie nennt man das so,
Alleinstellungsmerkmal,
oder herausstechende Merkmal war,
die Dinger hatten alle eine vollständige Tastatur.
Also du konntest damit theoretisch tippen.
Und wie iPhone Zeiten noch,
was die Leute auch gerne hatten,
Blackberry,
tja, ich weiß nicht, wie diese Dinger heißen,
halt mit so nem Keyboard, ja.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
So modern,
so modern war das nicht,
was es damals gegeben hat.
Ja, eher solche Sachen,
aber so modern war das auch noch nicht.
Und eine Zeit lang waren diese Blackberry Dinger
übelst angesagt.
Und warum?
Wegen Push-Mail.
Das war damals der neueste Shit.
Und das haben die sich ja auch
jahrelang drauf ausgeruht.
Ich fand die Dinger damals schon schrottig.
Ja, Formfaktor passt schon.
Zeig mal, was ist das für eins.
So ein Teil.
Nee, so ein Ding hatte ich nicht.
Ich hatte früher nen Siemens-Handy,
ne ganze Weile.
So ein Teil hatte ich ne Weile, genau.
Ich glaube sogar das hier.
Und dann hatte ich so nen Nokia,
so ein ganz...
Ja.
So ein Teil hatte ich.
Guck mal, kann man sich heute noch kaufen.
Exakt dieses Ding.
Das war mein erstes Handy damals.
Das ist ein Ding, Alter.
Mit...
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob das schon Snake hatte überhaupt.
Aber ich hatte damals so nen Adapter,
Nokia-Kabel auf USB
und hatte mir so ne komische
Nokia, nennen wir es mal
Software runtergeladen.
Da konnte man so Custom-Icons
und so drauf machen.
Da fand ich mich extremst Hackerman damals.
So ein Teil hat meine Mutter damals gehabt,
so ein ähnliches Handy.
Oh, das war auch teuer,
das Telefonieren damals damit.
Wobei man sagen muss, ehrlich gesagt,
wenn man sich heute Preise anguckt,
ohne Flatrate ins Handynetz und so,
das ist auch unsinnig teuer
in Zeiten, wo eh alles eigentlich
VoIP ist.
Hast du dir damals auch über Infrarot
Kontakte übertragen?
Nee.
Kontakte übertragen
von einem Handy ins andere?
Da hab ich die SIM-Karte...
Ach nee, du meinst nicht zwischen meinen Geräten.
Damals waren die Kontakte
alle auf der SIM-Karte gespeichert
und du hast die SIM-Karte ins andere Handy
und hast alle Kontakte mit dabei.
Und dein erstes Handy war Nokia 3110.
Die waren auch sehr verbreitet.
Die waren auch extrem verbreitet.
Die kann ich mich auch noch erinnern.
Die Dinger kann man ja heute noch
auf Amazon kaufen,
weil es immer noch Leute gibt,
die sagen, ich will kein Smartphone,
gib mir mal sowas.
Achso, nö, das hab ich nicht gemacht.
Ja, damals konntest du ja nicht
wirklich im Internet surfen
mit solchen Dingern hier,
mit sowas konntest du ja nicht im Internet surfen.
Da konntest du WAP-Seiten aufmachen,
die waren abfuck teuer
und es war lahm und es war klein
und es hat gesackt.
Weiß nicht, WAP-Google, gibt's das noch?
Ah, anscheinend nicht.
Wahrscheinlich können das Browser gar nicht mehr.
Was ist Moncatos hier dran?
Ne, gibt's anscheinend nicht mehr.
Ja, da weißt du ja noch,
wie grausam das war.
Not found.
Ich weiß noch, in der Berufsschule 2007,
okay, ich weiß nicht welche,
aber wenn die TOS ist,
dann lieber nicht hier im Stream.
Ich weiß noch, damals in der Berufsschule 2007,
aber man darf nicht vergessen,
das ist die Zeit so rum,
da hatte ich immer einen,
der hat Bildzeitungen gelesen
am Hauptbahnhof über WAP.
Wahrscheinlich wäre es billiger gewesen,
der hätte sich das Ding gekauft.
Weiß nicht, was kostet so eine Bildzeitung?
90 Cent oder so?
Damals, das wäre billiger gewesen,
hätte er es gekauft,
anstatt es über WAP zu lesen.
WAP, das war echt so ein Ding.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
wofür das steht eigentlich,
WAP-Internet.
Wireless Application Protocol, WAP.
Okay.
Ich habe mal,
wo wir gerade dabei sind,
wie man damals sinnlos Geld ausgeben konnte.
Ich habe damals,
warte mal,
ich habe damals auch
mal
auf so einer Dating-Seite
über
so einen SMS-Service,
sowas bescheuertes,
ich weiß auch nicht, wie ich oft,
na gut, ich war jung
und dachte mir,
Gucci Buzz.
Das war wenigstens keine Fake-Seite.
Das war nicht so wie heute teilweise,
irgendwelche Fake-Seiten,
wo dann irgendwelche Mädels dir schreiben,
die es gar nicht gibt und sowas.
Das war schon Vermittlung und so.
Aber es war,
es war halt so darauf ausgelegt,
dass die halt irgendwie einen Euro pro SMS verdienen daran.
Und das Erste, was ich geschrieben habe, ist,
so irgendwie, ich weiß nicht mehr, irgendwie,
so wie man es halt versucht,
man versucht dann irgendwie irgendwas,
was Sympathisches draufzuschreiben.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung mehr, was das war.
Und ich habe dann bei der zweiten Message
gleich nach der Handynummer gefragt.
Damals schon Geld saven.
Ja, wir haben dann irgendwie 5 Messages ausgetauscht
und dann war Ruhe.
Dann war Ruhe.
Ha, ha, ha.
Hat nichts, also, keine Ahnung.
Aber da konntest du schon,
über SMS-Services konntest du schon unglaublich viel Geld ausgeben.
Ja, vor allem, wo man auch damals aufpassen musste,
sind diese Boomer-Stories,
das verstehen die Leute von heute gar nicht.
Wenn du über 150 Zeichen geschrieben hast,
dann hattest manche Handys,
haben dann einfach eine zweite SMS hintendran gehängt.
Und du hast dann für drei Zeichen
eine zweite SMS bezahlen müssen.
Und solche Geschichten.
Und dann waren es 160 Zeichen.
Was weiß ich?
Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das ausschalten konnte.
Ne, sagt mir nichts.
50 Frei-SMS im Monat.
OMG.
Ja.
Es gab damals schon viel, viel Shit.
Aber heute gibt es genauso viel Shit.
Sogar mehr.
Weil eben die Internetnutzung viel verbreiteter ist.
Ja, MMS war ja eh der größte Scam überhaupt.
Warum das so teuer war?
Okay, ich weiß, warum das so teuer war.
Weil es nur absolute PPGas benutzt haben.
MMS.
Und dann, nach ein paar Jahren,
also gerade auch als das,
ich würde mal sagen, so ein paar Jahre nach iPhone-Release,
kam mir dann irgendwann WhatsApp auf.
Und damals die ganzen Boomer-Leute, Alter.
Ich kann mich immer noch dran erinnern.
Oh, kennst du schon diese neue App?
Damit kann man kostenlos SMS verschicken.
Oh, das ist so geil.
Und da musst du dir WhatsApp installieren.
Leute, seid ihr so dämlich?
Das sind keine SMS.
Das sind ganz normale Instant-Mess...
Das sind stinknormale Instant-Messenger.
Das Einzige, was die richtig gemacht haben,
im Vergleich zu ICQ und dem ganzen anderen Shit,
den es damals gegeben hat, ist,
die haben die Handynummer zur Identifikation genommen.
Fertig.
Und ich glaube, hat WhatsApp nicht das Problem,
dass die Leute,
wenn sie ein Handy haben,
und ich glaube,
hat WhatsApp nicht damals sogar noch was gekostet?
Ja, deswegen ist die kostenpflichtig,
weil es seine Oma noch benutzt.
Ja, nur auf iOS. Okay.
Was macht eigentlich ICQ so,
wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Warte mal, da traue ich mich gerade nicht drauf.
Das waren irgendwelche Russen früher.
Also die letzten paar Jahre.
Ich mache mal kurz meine 4M an.
Ich will mal kurz gucken, was ICQ so macht gerade.
Gibt es ICQ eigentlich mittlerweile als App für iOS?
Also nicht, dass ihr denkt,
ich will das installieren oder sowas.
Ich will einfach nur mal gucken.
Interessiert mich einfach gerade mal, was...
ICQ.
Damit ich auch richtig tippe.
ICQ Messenger. Stay connected.
Au.
Oder besser gesagt, au.
Aber immer noch besser als...
Hä?
Fuck, die updaten das ja immer noch.
Moment, das gehörte mal AOL?
Ja.
Was soll denn das? Gibt es...
Die Seite ist ein bisschen pp-iger, oder?
User account.
Oder number, number.
Wie viel haben die heute so?
Ich glaube, die geben keinerlei Daten raus.
Man weiß das nicht.
ICQ.
Ja, ICQ war damals richtig angesagt.
Damals konnte man...
ICQ hatte solche Minigames.
Kennt noch irgendjemand Sumo-Volleyball?
Wenn ich das richtig schreibe. Sumo-Volleyball?
Ja, das da.
Sumo-Volleyball.
Das gab es damals bei ICQ als Minigame.
Minigame.
Ne, das ist nicht das ICQ-Game.
Da konnte man nicht auf die Seite.
ICQ.
Nicht ICQ.
ICQ Sumo-Volleyball.
Ja, genau das.
Genau das.
Das waren so Minigames damals.
Das war ein Minigames,
bevor man es Minigame genannt hat.
Es gab total viel.
Ne, die war nicht neunstellig.
Die war später neunstellig,
weil es viele User gab.
Ja, Leute.
Das waren noch wilde Internetzeiten mit ICQ.
Damals hat man auch Sachen noch gespielt.
Überlegt euch mal.
Das waren Zeiten,
da hat man noch CS gespielt.
Also CS 1.6,
bevor es 1.6 war.
Das war damals noch 0.5.2 und sowas.
Und meine Lieblings-Map damals war Assault.
Geisel-Rettung.
Assault.
Das spielt jetzt keiner mehr.
Ich glaube, die Map gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Jabber.
Habe ich nur ganz kurz benutzt, Jabber.
Also ich überlege gerade.
Also ich würde sagen,
meine Instant-Messenger-Journey
war tatsächlich ICQ.
Ich habe nebenbei immer ein paar ausprobiert,
aber ich bin jahrelang
auf ICQ hängen geblieben.
Bisschen Jabber habe ich auch so benutzt.
Aber hauptsächlich ICQ.
Später ein bisschen Jabber,
aber weiter hauptsächlich ICQ.
Und dann halt Skype.
Hatte ich auch, hatte ich auch.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
es war hauptsächlich ICQ.
Damals auch so im Gaming-Umfeld.
Teamspeak hat man ja auch immer,
die immer noch die Server gehabt,
die immer noch rumgehangen hat.
Aber insgesamt würde ich sagen ICQ
und dann eigentlich schon Skype.
Ja, würde ich sagen.
ICQ, dann Skype
und jetzt halt eigentlich nur noch Discord.
Oh, Vendrillo fand ich nicht gut.
Es gab ja damals noch für Shooter-Spieler,
die haben damals gerne noch
Roger Wilco benutzt.
Das war auch so eine Crap-Software.
Ja.
Guckt euch das her, Leute.
Sowas haben die Leute damals noch,
sowas haben die Leute damals für Voice-Chat benutzt.
Teamspeak will ja Discord-Konkurrenz machen.
Ehrlich gesagt,
der Zug ist abgefahren.
Das Einzige,
und ich glaube wirklich,
das Einzige,
wo die Discord-Konkurrenz machen können,
ist in dem Punkt, was Discord nicht hat.
Und das ist die Möglichkeit,
Discord zu nutzen.
Alles andere ist Discord viel zu etabliert
und wenn die nicht irgendwas mega Tolles finden,
wo die Leute drauf gewartet haben
oder was so viel einfacher und besser ist
und überhaupt werden die Leute weiterhin Discord benutzen.
Der einzige Grund, Teamspeak zu benutzen,
ist zum Selbsthosten.
Fertig.
Zum Selbsthosten und wenn man halt gute Qualität
ohne Discord-Premium-Server und sowas haben will.
Kann man machen.
Es hat durchaus seine Daseinsberechtigung
und auch was Latenz und sowas angeht
und gerade für
im E-Sport-Bereich, wenn die online spielen,
da macht es schon einen Unterschied,
ob du 150 Millisekunden Latenz beim Labern hast
oder nur 20.
Ganz einfach, weil man TS
nicht so ohne weiteres in der großen Variante
selbst hosten kann.
Also ich glaube, TS ist nur bis 30 Slots
kostenlos zum Selbsthosten.
Den Rest braucht man,
den Rest muss man bezahlen.
Und das ist gar nicht so billig.
Und wenn man es sich bei einem Hosting-Anbieter bestellt,
dann kostet es halt gar nicht so viel mehr,
als wenn du es kaufen würdest.
Also die geben das auch nur weiter.
Teamspeak hat unsinnige Preise.
Ich meine klar,
jemand, der es so wirklich betreiben will,
der findet wahrscheinlich irgendwelche
Sicherheitskopien von Teamspeak im Internet.
Aber normalerweise reicht ja auch
ein 30-Slot-Server ohne Probleme.
Ein Teamspeak-Server, kein Discord.
Warum du so viel zahlen solltest,
weil es halt nun mal so viel kostet
und es war anders auch nicht billig,
also entweder du bezahlst es
oder du kriegst halt keinen Server.
Easy.
Oder dann sind es 32 Slots maximal.
Ja, das kann sein.
Was ist das?
Das ist schon scheiße.
Ne, ist sie nicht.
Die Server-Software von Teamspeak ist nicht frei.
Teamspeak, bye.
Free ist es nur bis 32 Slots.
Der Rest ist
ordentlich teuer.
Purchase.
Okay.
Teamspeak-Pricing.
Naja, ordentlich ist es auch übertrieben.
Also,
kostet dich im Jahr 55 Euro,
wenn du 64 slots.
Die Lizenz.
Nicht das Hosten.
Die Lizenz kostet dich 55 Dollar.
Dann brauchst du noch einen Server,
auf dem du es laufen lässt.
Und das sollte für 64 Slots
wahrscheinlich auch nicht das Schlechteste sein,
wenn du denkst,
dass es auch ausgelastet wird.
Die Single-Core-Halbes-Gig-Gramm oder so.
Ja.
Was ist eigentlich gerade mit Reddit los?
Viele Subreddits streiken,
oder ich nenne es mal so,
weil, genau, wegen der Reddit-RP,
die jetzt unsinnig viel Geld kosten soll.
Und damit Third-Party-Apps quasi
unterbindet.
Nicht verbietet, aber unterbindet.
Das ist das, was gerade auf Reddit abgeht.
Das heißt,
dass diese Software nur für 32
steht da, guck.
Ja.
Die Free-License ist nur für 32 User kostenlos.
Bis zu 32 User.
Das wäre cool.
Hätten die mich jetzt gesponsert,
hätte ich jetzt richtig nice
einen Sellout an der Stelle platzieren können.
Aber ich habe für dieses Jahr nichts.
Ich müsste eigentlich mal wieder
mit denen reden,
ob wir nicht irgendwas machen wollen
Ende des Jahres.
Würde sich ja wieder mal anbieten.
Nee, der Code ist,
der Code, der geht gerade nicht.
So, was haben wir denn?
Lasst uns mal ein bisschen was angucken.
Was?
Max, kennst du einen guten Provider
für Mails?
Soll das ein richtig echter Mail-Server sein?
Also willst du darüber auch E-Mails verschicken
oder nur empfangen?
Nur empfangen ist easy.
Auch verschicken?
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, kann sein.
Dann musst du alles selbst machen
und Mail-Server selbst machen,
ist ziemlich eklig.
Genau, Cloudflare habe ich auch
für so einfache Dinger nur empfangen.
Da machst du einen Redirect rein und fertig.
So, lass mal kurz gucken.
Was können wir uns jetzt mal?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich kann mir kein Levelcap-PP-Geheim angucken.
Reddit.
How GitHub database self-destructed.
Ah, nee, das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Nee, ich wollte mir noch ein Video angucken
von Technikkeller.
Was ist das?
Das hier.
Genau, weil von ihm haben wir uns
letztens auch ein Video angeguckt,
wo er sich über die Abschlussprüfung ausgelassen hat.
Von ihm haben wir letztens ein Video geguckt,
Nämlich das hier.
IHK.
Das da.
Nee, IHK.
Ja.
Da habe ich sogar drauf reacted
eines meiner wenigen Reaction-Videos auf YouTube.
Und anscheinend hat er seine Abschlussprüfung,
seine mündliche Abschlussprüfung jetzt gehabt.
Da bin ich mal gespannt,
was da rausgekommen ist.
Ich hoffe mal, dass er es geschafft hat.
Also hoffe ich wirklich für ihn,
weil er hat ja sehr viel Pech gehabt
mit seiner letzten Ausbildung.
Wobei ich gehe davon aus,
dass er die geschafft hat,
weil, naja, sonst würde er wahrscheinlich
so kein Video drüber machen.
Wobei ich ihm auch durchaus zutrauen würde,
dass er ein Video drüber macht,
wenn er es nicht geschafft hat.
Wenn er zu optimistisch ist,
wo er erzählt hat so,
ja, die Aufgabe habe ich nicht gemacht
oder das habe ich mal einfach geskippt.
Aber wird schon eine 3 sein
und wird schon reichen.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt nicht zu optimistisch ist,
wie er das Ganze sieht.
Aber wahrscheinlich hat er es geschafft.
Ich muss mal kurz was trinken.
Es hat mich noch keiner ans Trinken erinnert, Leute.
So, trinke.
Ja, jetzt ist es auch zu spät.
Ihr könnt natürlich ruhig eure Punkte jetzt raus.
Jetzt ist es aber auch zu spät.
Ich habe mich vom Rechner gesetzt.
Vorher habe ich schon was genommen.
Leute, wisst ihr, was ich heute gegessen habe?
Naja, natürlich wisst ihr das nicht.
Nein, ich wollte euch Cheatbaden.
Ich wollte euch Cheatbaden.
Ich habe darauf gewartet,
dass jemand sagt, Nudeln mit Lachs.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe heute mexikanisch gefuttert.
Und zwar habe ich heute gefuttert
Frankfurt Chidoba.
Das ist so eine Fast Food.
Ja, wirklich Fast Food.
Doch, das ist quasi so ein Subway
Ich dachte, die haben Bilder von ihrem Essen vielleicht.
Produkte.
Okay.
Burritos.
Chicken, Beef Burrito.
Sowas habe ich heute gegessen.
Naja, ganz so geil sah der jetzt nicht aus.
Aber so in der Richtung.
Allerdings habe ich das als Menü gegessen.
Das heißt, dazu kam noch eine Fanta
und so Gewürze.
Ja, genau.
Mit so Mexikanischen Gewürzen.
Chips.
Nicht Chips, Pommes Frites.
Schmeckt immer ganz nice.
Das kann ich auch empfehlen.
Ich habe euch ja schon erzählt,
dass ich bei vielen Fast Food Dinger
oder auch bei vielen Restaurants in Frankfurt
teilweise ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen kriege.
Weiß man nie, wie gut das mit der Verdauung geht.
Bei denen habe ich selten Probleme gehabt bisher.
Also kann man empfehlen.
Es ist preislich nicht super billig.
Es war früher sogar relativ teuer.
Aber nachdem alles andere mittlerweile
mega teuer geworden ist
und die Preise nicht richtig erhöht haben,
ist es preislich eigentlich mittlerweile ganz okay.
Also man bezahlt 12 Euro für ein Menü.
Da kann man sich dann aussuchen,
was man haben will.
Plus Pommes Frites oder Chips
oder Fries, Fried Dinger und was zu trinken.
Das ist okay.
Wieso isst man da Salat?
Das verstehe ich auch nicht.
Ich war mal bei so einem Burgerladen in Frankfurt
und da hat allen Ernstes jemand einen Burger bestellt.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war.
Ich hätte gerne Bacon, Cheese, sonst was, Burger.
Und dann wollten die den Burger für den machen
beziehungsweise haben die Bestellung aufgenommen.
Und dann meinte er aber im Salat.
Das habe ich ja zum ersten Mal gesehen,
dass das überhaupt möglich ist.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, was?
Burger im Salat?
Und anscheinend war das in diesem Restaurant möglich.
Ja, du konntest das Brot weglassen
und du hast dann dafür so Eisbergsalat
um deinen Burger drum herum gewickelt bekommen.
Das Unsinnigste, was ich überhaupt jemals gesehen habe.
Keine Ahnung, warum er dann einen Burger futtert.
Also dann gehe ich lieber um die Ecke
und hole mir bei irgendeinem Laden halt einen Salat.
Und dann kann ich ja auch mit Hähnchen oder sonst was holen.
Ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Was ich auch nicht verstehe ist,
Leute, die zum Subway gehen, das verstehe ich auch nicht.
Die gehen zum Subway und machen dann irgendwie
Ja, ich hätte gerne so Sub des Tages
oder hier Chicken Teriyaki Sub, aber als Salat.
Was ist mit euch los?
Wenn ich das haben will,
ich sage ja nichts dagegen, dass jemand gerne Salat isst.
Das ist ja okay.
Ich esse auch ganz gerne Salat.
Mit ordentlich was drin.
Aber dann noch kein Sandwich als Salat
und kein Burger als Salat.
Aber gut.
Unterm Strich soll jeder futtern, worauf er Bock hat.
Ich verstehe es bloß nicht.
Ja und warum hast du es dann geholt?
Warum bist du nicht einfach irgendwo Salat essen gegangen?
Okay, also gucken wir uns mal das wieder an.
Ach so.
Ja okay, dann verstehe ich.
Aber die hätten doch bestimmt noch einfach einen Salat gemacht
in dem Restaurant, wo das war.
Aber okay, dann verstehe ich.
Wenn man halt mit einem Team irgendwie Teambuildingabend
was auch immer macht
und man geht halt in einen Burgerladen
und man ist halt mit Salat.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Aber ich gehe doch nicht Mittagessen irgendwo hin,
wo ich es mir aussuchen kann
und bestelle dann einen Burger,
der in Eisbergsalat eingepackt ist.
Aber ich verstehe dich.
Ich vertrage auch viele Sachen nicht.
Ich bin da immer, wenn ich irgendwo Neues hingehe,
bin ich immer skeptisch.
Ich vertrage vieles nicht gut.
Und nachdem ich schon,
ihr kennt ja noch meine Story,
die habe ich ja mal in einem Video verarbeitet,
wo ich ultra dringend kacken musste
und ich dann in den Klo gehen musste,
der erst gebootet hat.
Kein Witz, Leute.
Ein Klo, der gebootet hat.
Ihr könnt euch das nicht vorstellen,
aber der Klo hat wirklich gebootet.
Das stand auf dem Display drauf.
Booting.
Seitdem bin ich vorsichtig,
wenn ich noch ein paar Stunden in Frankfurt bin,
Futter.
Ja, nice.
Vor allem von der Steuer.
Steuerbeste.
Oh, das ist bestimmt Toss.
Ich bin gespannt,
was bei seiner Abschlussprüfung rauskommt.
Da bin ich wirklich,
wie sagt man es?
Oh, Null, komm.
Alter, YouTube gebated wieder.
Da bin ich wirklich,
wirklich mega gespannt drauf.
Okay, anscheinend hat das geschafft.
Ich muss ihm auch mal kurz was unter das Video schreiben,
falls ich noch eingeloggt bin im zweiten Browser.
Ich schreibe einfach runter
GG
Eats.
Gut gemacht.
Das Video auf YouTube ist übrigens sehr beliebt.
Ich habe,
ich habe ja vor ein paar Tagen ein Video hochgeladen.
Vor ein paar Tagen ist gut,
vor elf Tagen.
Und das hat die ersten Tage
nicht so gut performt.
Ich gebe ja auch zu,
das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so das Thema,
was jetzt alle wahnsinnig interessiert.
Aber das hat 10.000 Views gemacht
die letzten zwei Tage,
oder letzten zwei, drei Tage.
Noch mal nachträglich.
Und wenn ich mir den Graph angucke,
das geht immer weiter hoch.
Das ist so ein typisches Video,
was in einem halben Jahr 70.000 Aufrufe dann hat.
Ich glaube aber, das ist halt ein Thema,
was jetzt nicht direkt
alle von meinen hier Subscribern installiert,
äh, installiert, Alter,
interessiert,
aber durch die Recommendations auf YouTube
eben breite, breiteren Anklang findet.
Schicke gerade Werbung ab
mit den dreistesten Gehaltvorschlägen.
Doch, ich habe mir sogar schon ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben.
Ich muss das echt aufnehmen jetzt,
weil sonst ist ja wieder outdated, overrated, debated.
Ähm, was forderst du denn da so?
Erhelle uns mal.
Das ist nämlich eine Frage,
die hier im Stream immer kommt, ist,
was kann ich zum Einstieg verlangen?
Oder was kann ich in dieser,
erzähl mal.
Was sind denn da so,
was sind für dich dreiste Gehaltsvorstellungen?
Also natürlich wäre es,
wäre es interessant,
so ein bisschen, was du,
und als was, ja.
Also falls du was zu schreiben willst, ja.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit,
den, was, den gebraucht bei PRs immer?
Ja, gibt Schlimmeres.
Ich habe heute gehört,
von meinem alten Arbeitgeber,
ich habe ja immer noch ein bisschen Kontakt
mit, mit den Leuten.
Sie haben den ersten,
weil ihnen ja alle Leute weggerannt sind, ja,
also, also,
Kollege von mir und ich sind ja nicht die Einzigen,
es sind ja total viele abgehauen
und haben gesagt, ich hau ab.
Sie haben jetzt,
nachdem ihnen quasi die Hälfte,
das ist ein bisschen übertrieben,
30, 40% aber der IT-Leute
weggerannt sind,
haben sie jetzt gesagt,
fuck, wir müssen den Leuten,
glaube ich, mehr Geld geben.
Und jetzt haben sie einem angeboten,
der vorher auch schon irgendwie
viel zu wenig verdient hat
und jetzt auch gesagt hat,
Alter, ich hau ab,
haben sie angeboten 5K mehr
und er hat gesagt,
mach ich nicht, woanders kriege ich 15K mehr.
Pech gehabt, würde ich sagen.
Also sprich, der ist auch weg.
Ich schicke gerade 85K Euro für euren Job.
Ja.
Ich denke, 85K
für einen easy life,
chilliger Job
ist das durchaus in Ordnung.
Oh, nice.
Da kannst du ja aber richtig was für leisten.
Okay.
Oh, mir juckt die Nase.
Dann lass uns das mal kurz angucken.
17 Minuten.
Moin.
Ich möchte in diesem Video
einmal kurz ein paar Erfahrungen
von der Abschlussprüfung
nochmal hervorholen,
bisschen was darüber erzählen,
also größtenteils über den mündlichen Teil
bzw. die Projektpräsentation.
Ich habe auch schon ein Video gemacht
zum schriftlichen Teil,
so irgendwie mit Themen,
wie Jobautomatisierung.
Ich war viel zu lang in der Bank
und jetzt in der Versicherung,
dass ich weiß, was Batchautomatisierung ist.
Da kennst du bestimmt auch
den U-Broker-Demon, oder?
Sergeant Silver, U-Broker-D
und solche Geschichten.
Das ist ja IBM Jobautomatisierung
und Jobausführung und sowas.
Nee, ich dachte,
dass das Ding U-Broker meint.
U-Broker IBM.
Oh, doch.
Nee, das wird was Falsches.
Da habe ich vergessen,
was ist U-Broker?
Nee, das ist doch irgendwas anderes.
Universal U-Broker.
Nee, sowas hatten wir nämlich.
Ich dachte, es hat was damit zu tun.
Also dort, wo ich war,
war es U-Broker.
Das hatte auch was mit...
Ja, ist es.
Wobei man sagen muss,
es muss nicht mehr zwangsläufig Kobold sein.
Man kann nämlich mittlerweile auch...
Also, nee, Blödsinn.
Es ist falsch.
Es muss oftmals nicht mehr direkt
das Oldschool-Kobold sein.
Es gibt mittlerweile auch
Laufzeitumgebungen,
wo man Kobold auf Java laufen lassen kann.
Sowas hatten wir bei der Bank
beim alten Arbeitgeber.
Die haben ihre Kobold-Geschichten,
ihre 30, 50, 180 Jahre alten
Ach gut, so krass vielleicht nicht
Java-Kobold-Dinger
umwandeln lassen in Java-Zeug,
dass es auf der JVM laufen kann.
Ganz abenteuerliches Zeug,
was da alles so gemacht wird.
Okay, zeig mal her.
Also, hat er es jetzt geschafft?
Ich gehe davon aus,
weil so viele Glückwünsche
in den Kommentaren waren.
Wenn ich jetzt drunter kommentiert hätte,
hätte es nicht geschafft.
Also, hätte ich das drunter kommentiert
und er hätte es jetzt nicht geschafft,
wäre echt Fail, oder?
In Foren noch geschaut habe,
und irgendwas.
Ja, das war Blödsinn mit IHK-Verklagen,
das habe ich auch mal im Video gesagt.
Verlinke das Video mal,
am besten hier,
oder unten in der Beschreibung
soll es auch drin stehen.
Ich hatte so ein halbes,
schlimmes Gefühl gehabt.
Jarek, in welchem Bereich
und in welcher,
also, welcher Bereich,
welche Branche, welcher Standort,
dann können wir vielleicht
mit ein bisschen Chat
was zu sagen.
Na, also, 35k,
ich schraube sie sehr wenig.
Wie gesagt, mein Einstiegsgehalt,
und das ist lange her,
beim Provider war 33.500.
Suche jetzt was,
aber alles hört sich kacke an.
Ja, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Also, hättest du jetzt irgendwie
mal konkret was gesagt?
Ich habe mich beworben als,
was kann ich da sagen?
Ich meine, das kann man so nicht pauschal sagen,
weil,
nur weil du Physik gelernt hast,
du kannst ja alles machen.
Und natürlich kriegst du
als Druckerpatronentauscher
nicht so viel wie als Admin
oder als
Cloud-Engineer
oder sonst was.
Ja, ich denke, 45k ist schon okay
als Einstiegsgehalt,
wobei, ganz ehrlich,
in der aktuellen Zeit dürfte es
auch ein bisschen mehr sein.
Aber je nach Bundesland
und Region
und Branche, vielleicht 45k auch okay.
Ja,
Jahresgehalt brauchen wir.
Weil, man kann das jetzt zwar mal 12 rechnen,
aber, das ist ja oftmals nicht so,
na, das ist zu wenig.
Das ist zu wenig.
Also, wenn es mal 12 gerechnet wird,
ist es zu wenig.
Aber selbst wenn es mal 14,
mal 14 kann es vielleicht
fürs erste Jahr noch in Ordnung gehen,
aber es ist zu wenig.
Also, 31k ist viel zu wenig.
Das ist ja nix
in der heutigen Zeit.
Da kannst du ja noch nicht mal
gescheit eine Wohnung bezahlen
und morgens mit dem Auto zur Arbeit fahren,
das ist übertrieben gesagt.
Wohnung bezahlen, essen, vorbei.
Nee, das ist scheiße.
Ja, ist es denn mal 12
oder bekommt ihr 14 Monatsgelder
oder sowas?
Nee, das ist kacke.
Also, 31k im Jahr ist ja nix.
Ich habe meine Ausbildung,
also sprich, ich habe 2007
die Ausbildung gemacht
und danach der Ausbildung
habe ich 33.500 damals
beim Internetprovider bekommen.
Und du kannst davon ausgehen,
das ist 15 Jahre her,
naja, nicht ganz,
ich habe die Ausbildung mal ein bisschen später fertig,
aber 13 Jahre her,
und dann runde mal einfach auf,
15 Jahre her, ist scheiß drauf.
Und da war es schon mehr
und in den 15 Jahren
war es schon mehr.
Soll ich dir mal ehrlich sagen,
ich hasse
Online-Marketing-Agenturen und Leute.
Mittlerweile,
da hat mich YouTube zugebracht.
Nicht alle, muss ich sagen.
Es gibt genug,
die sind durchaus nett
und auch,
die wollten dich auch nicht bescheißen.
Zum Beispiel die bei Hetzner
hatte ich nicht den Eindruck,
dass die einen irgendwie bescheißen wollten.
Oder auch damals von Elgato,
das hast du auch gleich gemerkt.
Aber die meisten
Online-Marketing-Sachen,
das ist so ein Bullshit alles.
Die verkaufen dir morgens ihre Oma
und abends hauen sie dich in die Pfanne mit irgendwas.
Das sind ganz komische Leute.
Also ganz ehrlich,
ich glaube Online-Marketing
zieht
mit, also vom Beruf her,
zieht das mit
die schleimigsten
und
wie soll man sagen,
die schleimigsten
und unangenehmsten Personen an,
die es so gibt.
Ich meine jetzt nicht in der Technik.
Ich meine die,
die im Marketing-Bereich arbeiten.
Und das Schlimme ist,
die meisten kannst du komplett in die Tonne kloppen.
Die können nichts.
Die können auch nicht mal das,
was sie machen sollen gut.
Aber die schwätzen einen Scheiß
und du weißt,
die meisten,
ohne Mist,
die meisten Online-Marketing-Leute,
du darfst denen nichts glauben.
Nee, oberflächlich ist das das falsche Wort.
Da habe ich ja noch nichts,
da war es dagegen, oberflächlich.
Da geht die Sache schnell,
zielorientiert,
die labern einen Scheiß alle.
Und ich glaube,
das Erste, was die meisten Online-Marketing-Leute machen,
ist ein Kurs,
wie macht man möglichst viel leere Versprechungen.
Die labern alle
und Leute,
ohne Scheiß,
was nicht im Vertrag steht,
wird auch nicht gemacht.
Beziehungsweise,
muss man nicht davon ausgehen,
dass sie dann irgendwas machen,
nur weil es da nicht steht.
Und wisst ihr,
was eines der Lieblings-Ausreden ist,
Leute, wo ihr nie drauf hören solltet,
dass so aus 15 Jahren,
na gut, stimmt nicht,
aus 13 Jahren YouTube
und Online-Influencer-Business,
wenn euch einer was anbietet
und ihr findet das eigentlich ganz gut,
ihr kriegt einen Vertrag zugeschickt,
ihr lest den Vertrag durch
und euch fallen ein paar komische Dinge im Vertrag auf.
Es ist nicht egal, um was genau,
euch fallen ein paar komische Dinge im Vertrag auf
und ihr sagt dann, ja okay,
ihr schreibt hier beispielsweise,
ihr bekommt auch Rechte,
mein Logo und sowas zu verwerten,
für alles mögliche,
das ist ja hier überhaupt nicht eingeschränkt,
wie soll ich mir das vorstellen,
ihr könnt jetzt mein Logo einfach überall verwenden,
ohne im Zusammenhang,
ja okay,
dann hast du Rückfragen dazu,
das gefällt dir so nicht,
weil das für dich viel zu weit gefasst ist
und wenn ihr dann als Antwort bekommt,
ach, macht dir mal keine Gedanken,
das ist bei uns normal,
dass die Verträge so geschrieben sind.
Das ist allgemein so geschrieben in den Verträgen,
aber macht dir mal keine Gedanken,
wir benutzen das nur
im Zusammenhang mit dem Video.
Leute, geht davon aus,
wenn das im Vertrag drin steht,
dass ihr den Rechte für euer Logo
und euer Kanal
für Marketingzwecke gebt,
wenn da nicht explizit drinsteht,
es ist gebunden an die Kooperation,
dann machen die das auch,
dann halten die sich da auch nicht dran.
Du kannst dich,
also das habe ich wirklich gelernt,
du kannst dich auf Aussagen dieser Leute
nicht verlassen.
Die lügen,
die lügen dich an,
wissentlich.
Und eine Sache,
die man bei Marketingleuten ganz oft sieht,
also gerade bei Online-Marketingleuten,
die sind vornherum
ultra fake-freundlich,
aber sie verarschen dich
bei der ersten Gelegenheit.
Nicht alle, wie gesagt,
aber viele,
viel zu viele.
Ihr dürft denen überhaupt nichts glauben.
Und wenn einer sagt,
ach, unsere Verträge sind nun mal
so, dass wir davon ausgehen,
im Zweifelsfall wird irgendwas gemacht,
was ihr nicht wollt.
Das ist voll für den Arsch,
dieses ganze Online-Marketing-Business.
Ich meine jetzt nicht dich als Web-Entwickler
und nicht die Leute, die in der IT arbeiten,
aber die Marketingleute an sich ganz abartig.
Und es geht tatsächlich auch in ganz gut.
Also,
wisst ihr, was ich in letzter Zeit
tatsächlich, also von welchem Unternehmen ich,
ich kenne ja so die letzten Jahre über,
so die hatte man ja,
ich meine, ihr wisst,
ich bin nicht der krasseste Socializer,
ich kenne nicht 100.000 Leute,
aber mit ein paar hat man so die letzten Jahre
über immer Kontakt gehabt
und hat auch immer mal wieder
so ein bisschen Kontakt noch.
Wisst ihr, was tatsächlich das Unternehmen ist,
wo ich bisher aus der Marketing-Abteilung,
also von Mitarbeitern,
es geht jetzt nicht darum,
dass ich mit denen schon was gemacht hätte,
wo ich von Mitarbeitern bisher,
was Betriebsklima
und generelle Sachen angeht,
noch, also nein,
ich rede nicht von Edeka und sowas,
sondern von wirklich so
Online-Influencer-Marketing-Zeug,
das Unternehmen, wo ich noch
das Beste in letzter Zeit von gehört habe,
ihr werdet es nicht glauben,
aber das ist TikTok.
Ich habe viel, also,
ich kenne nur einen,
der bei TikTok arbeitet,
aber was ich von dem gehört habe,
ist tatsächlich,
bisher von den ganzen Marketing-Dingern,
was ich so mitbekommen habe,
würde man gar nicht so vermuten,
dass irgendwie,
nee, aber anscheinend,
was man da so hört,
arbeitsklimatechnisch
und auch generell,
wie das gemacht ist,
soll das wirklich ganz angenehm sein,
TikTok-Influencer-Marketing,
dort zu arbeiten.
Ich sage jetzt nicht,
dass sie nicht auch die Leute bescheißen,
das werden sie garantiert machen,
weil jeder Online-Marketing-Leute
die Leute bescheißen,
wird in letzter Zeit zumindest ernsthaft
von TikTok gehört,
man wird es gar nicht glauben, ja.
Aber nochmal zu deiner Sache,
Swartberg,
nach neun Jahren 43k als Entwickler
ist wirklich nicht viel.
Also, ich würde sagen,
wenn jemand 45k als Einstiegsgehalt bekommt,
dann ist das durchaus im Rahmen,
ich kann das ja immer nur,
ich habe ja da selbst keine Erfahrung
in letzter Zeit,
ich kann das nur an meinem Einstiegsgehalt festmachen,
damals 33,5k nach der Ausbildung,
heute nach neun Jahren,
bist du jetzt ja auch kein Junior-Dev,
der keine zwei Zeilen Javascript
auf die Reihe kriegt,
oder gerade erst angefangen hat.
Hast du schon ein massiv hohes Angebot
von Kik bekommen?
Nein, ich glaube auch nicht,
dass ich die Zielgruppe bin,
die die Streamer-Gruppe,
die Kik haben will, ne.
Wobei, ich gucke mal,
aber glaube ich nicht,
aber ich suche mal,
Moment, Mail,
wo die,
wo die alle ihre Nudes drüber
verschickt haben früher,
ne, kam nix,
Kik bekommen kenne ich gar nicht,
also sich mal umzugucken,
ist auf jeden Fall in der heutigen Zeit
nicht verkehrt,
und vielleicht wirkt das auch Wunder,
Arbeitsklima war bei mir in der alten Firma
auch gut, im Team,
drumherum für'n Arsch,
ich kann ja aus eigener Erfahrung
was raten an der Stelle,
ich habe ja selbst den Job gewechselt
und ich weiß,
das kostet Überwindung
und man ist mega faul,
gerade wenn man sich seit knapp 10 Jahren
bei dir quasi
da eingewöhnt hat schon,
ja, das ist,
man ist da sehr,
wie soll man sagen,
sehr so im Alltagstrott drinnen
und ich weiß,
das ist schwierig,
sich zu überwinden,
aber ich will jetzt nicht diese Ansprache
Just do it machen und sonst was,
es geht dir nicht drum,
dass du dich irgendwie überwinden sollst
oder sonst was,
ne, was ich sagen will ist folgendes,
man muss ja gar nicht all in gehen,
so nach dem Motto,
ich fang jetzt an mich überall zu bewerben
oder sowas,
es reicht ja schon mal,
gerade wenn man nicht ganz zufrieden ist,
aber zufrieden genug,
dann schadet es schon mal nicht,
also ich mein,
von den üblichen Geschichten wie
vielleicht mal gucken,
es schadet ja schon mal nicht,
zumindest ab und zu mal anzufangen,
was es, zu gucken,
was Stellenanzeigen in der Nähe gibt,
das ist ja absolut nichts Verbindliches,
so und wenn du mal was Gutes findest,
mal ne Bewerbung irgendwo hinzuschicken,
ist ja auch gar kein Problem,
das muss dir auch nicht an die große Glocke hängen,
außerdem hast du den Vorteil,
du kannst es ein bisschen üben,
falls es wirklich irgendwann mal akut wird,
dass du sagst,
ach ich will jetzt aber weg,
da hast du auf jeden Fall schon mal
das ganze das ja auch ohne Probleme,
wenn es gut läuft,
auch mal unverbindlich angucken,
mal vor Ort,
du bist ja zu nichts gezwungen
und irgendwann findest du vielleicht mal was,
wo du sagst,
ey, das finde ich richtig gut,
die sind in allen Belangen besser,
super Homeoffice-Regelung,
mehr Geld,
was auch sonst,
was dir da noch wichtig ist
und dann unterschreibst du über den,
du bist weg,
dann nehmen wir jetzt auch mal ordentlich mehr Kohle,
kann ja auch sein,
je nachdem wie dein Arbeitgeber drauf ist,
würde ich es gar nicht so sehr an die große Glocke hängen,
schon im Vorfeld,
es kann ja auch sein,
dass sie dann sagen,
ja ok, dann jetzt,
wie sagt man so,
hopp oder flopp,
jetzt mach halt,
keine Ahnung wie man darauf reagiert,
aber das muss ja auch gar keiner mitkriegen
und du hast eine super Position,
du kannst dich total entspannt bewerben
und total entspannt sein,
weil du brauchst es ja nicht,
das ist die beste Position, die es gibt,
um sich was Neues zu suchen
und wenn du dein LinkedIn-Profil aktualisierst,
kriegst du eh am Tag
75.000 sinnlose Headhunter-Anfragen,
vielleicht ist ja da auch irgendwas Sinnvolles dabei,
ja München ist halt mega teuer,
60k für 4 Tage Woche,
weiß gar nicht,
was ich beim alten Arbeitgeber
mit 4 Tage Woche wirklich hatte,
ich glaube ein bisschen weniger
oder auch so in dem Dreh
muss ich mal überlegen,
ne, ein bisschen weniger,
ne, ja, ja, ne,
ok, keine Ahnung,
was ist von 76k 20%
Quickmuffs,
16k oder so, ne,
irgendwie so in dem Dreh,
15,5 oder irgendwie sowas,
ja,
das ist doch ganz ok,
ich finde es auch schlimmer,
aber Online-Marketing-Leute
sind so unangenehme Leute,
wie kann ich mich denn am besten verkaufen,
wenn ich,
Moment, ich mach mal ein bisschen Musik wieder an,
bevor wir das Video jetzt gucken,
eigentlich wollte ich das Video jetzt gucken,
wie kann ich mich denn am besten verkaufen,
wenn ich keine Erfahrung habe,
außer Ausbildung,
Junior-IT-Stelle suchen,
naja,
was sind denn die Gebiete,
die dich interessieren,
also am besten ist natürlich,
wenn du dich persönlich auch schon
intensiver auseinandergesetzt hast,
das würde ich in meiner Bewerbung hervorheben,
also wenn es natürlich,
wenn es was ist, was dazu passt,
zu der Stelle,
und selbst, wenn es was ist,
was nicht passt,
es schadet auf jeden Fall nicht,
das zu erwähnen,
und ansonsten,
such dir halt was raus,
was sich anspricht,
die sind aktuell eh händeringend am suchen,
guck dir mal an,
schau dir mal das Beta-Profil mit,
wenn da irgendwas
Aussagekräftiges drauf ist,
du musst keine Junior-Stelle suchen,
also viele schreiben das gar nicht mit Junior,
also manche machen das,
das nimmt immer mehr,
also kommt auch in Deutschland immer mehr,
aber du kannst ohne Probleme,
keine Ahnung, such dir eine Systemadministrator-Stelle,
zum Beispiel,
wenn du Physik gelernt hast,
und das was ist, was dich interessiert,
natürlich nicht Windows,
also such dir sowas in der Richtung,
wenn das was ist, was dich interessiert,
dann ist auch egal,
ob da Junior davor steht oder nicht,
Junior ist eher so ein bisschen was,
in Richtung, bei Entwicklern,
wobei, wie gesagt,
ich weiß, es nimmt überall,
kommt da so ein bisschen mehr rein,
dass man da Junior dran schreibt,
und was nach Senior kommt,
ist bei vielen auch nicht ganz einheitlich,
du musst nicht explizit nach Junior-Stellen suchen,
du kannst auch ganz einfach nach normalen Stellen,
ohne irgendeinen
Skill-Level, nennen wir es mal,
da vorsuchen,
such dir halt Stellen,
wo das passt zu dem, was dich interessiert,
ich würde hauptsächlich gucken nach Stellen,
wo mich auch der Inhalt interessiert,
und wo du vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen Erfahrung hast,
mit dem, was sie da machen,
weil ganz im Ernst,
es hat ja keinen Sinn,
wenn du beispielsweise Linux-User bist,
oder Linux-Admin bist,
oder dich da im Linux-Umfeld gut auskennst,
und das ist, was dich privat interessiert,
und du dich dementsprechend auch damit auseinandersetzt,
um da reinzubewerben,
da kriegst du ja Zustände,
da drehst du dich durch,
da kriegst du irgendwie,
einen Schlaganfall oder so noch,
nach zwei Jahren,
also man muss da schon ein bisschen gucken,
weil das Feld ist halt auch sehr groß,
ans Trinken erinnern,
sehr gute Idee,
danke für die Subs Leute übrigens,
ich habe die Hälfte da vergessen,
gibt es noch diese Plattform,
wo Ninja mal drauf war,
nee, Ninja ist glaube ich schon wieder zurück auf Twitch,
Mixer, genau Mixer hieß der Gampel,
ja gibt es nicht mehr,
Kick ist Twitch für Casinos,
oh nee, so ein Schrott,
ja gut, wenn es Casinos sind,
das würde ja auch dazu passen,
der macht ja so viel Gamplingsachen,
oder macht das noch,
ich verfolge das nicht,
aber ja, das würde wahrscheinlich passen,
das stimmt,
also ich kann euch sagen,
die Stelle,
die ich jetzt angetreten habe,
am 1. April,
also die Linux,
die Senior Linux Stelle,
die Linux Engineer Stelle,
die war glaube ich ein halbes Jahr,
oder ein Dreivierteljahr,
im Stellenanzeigen Portal drin,
und wisst ihr,
ratet mal wie viele Bewerber die hatten,
auf die Stelle,
in dem Dreivierteljahr,
zwei,
nee, waren nicht zwei,
du,
ey,
eine,
also außer mir,
End of Function Zero,
du hast recht,
mit mir zwei,
es hat sich einer drauf beworben,
den wollten sie aber nicht,
kann ich auch verstehen,
das war ein Azubi,
der war frisch fertig,
und hat sich direkt auf eine Senior Stelle beworben,
das ist vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen sehr optimistisch,
und ich,
das ist wirklich mega 0815 gewesen,
so eine richtige Business Corporate Stelle,
wo man sich denkt,
die könnte eins zu eins
aus einem Stellenanzeigen Generator kommen,
also die Stellenanzeige war,
also vom Inhalt her,
muss man sagen,
war die nicht übel,
also man hat schon gemerkt,
dass die sich Gedanken drüber gemacht haben,
reinzuschreiben an Technologien
und Sachen die sie brauchen,
also die haben schon sich überlegt,
was ist jetzt der richtige Bewerber,
aber der Aufbau der Stellenanzeige
war halt mega 0815,
so aus dem Generator,
wir sind beste Versicherung aller Zeiten,
und führen im Bereich XY,
und da nach Für,
und wir suchen jemanden
mit Erfahrung im Linux Umfeld,
so richtig 0815,
so wie du es tausendfach siehst,
so nach dem Motto,
was wir bieten,
ein,
was schreiben sie da immer,
ein marktübliches Gehalt,
oder eine leistungsorientierte Vergütung,
oder sowas in der Richtung,
hätten die mal reingeschrieben,
wir bezahlen euch 115k im Jahr,
ja dann hätten sie sich sicherlich mehr beworben,
wobei das nicht stimmt,
nicht dass ihr jetzt denkt,
ich bekomme für,
ich chill da ab,
115k im Jahr,
nee, nee, nee, ist das nicht,
also allein schon mit 4 Tage Woche nicht,
aber ich glaube,
hätten die das reingeschrieben,
Gehaltsspanne,
keine Ahnung,
90 bis 115k,
dann wären auch ein paar Bewerbungen reingekommen,
wenn man da aber nur reinschreibt,
ein marktübliches Gehalt,
oder irgendwie eine leistungsorientierte Vergütung,
ja da kann es ja keiner,
das schreibt ja jeder rein,
hätten die mal reingeschrieben,
wir haben eine Kantine,
das wäre auch irgendwie ein Pluspunkt gewesen,
also,
es war auf jeden Fall sehr 0815,
und im Endeffekt,
bin ich nur,
also habe ich mich da nur beworben,
einzig und allein aus dem Grund,
das war ein riesen Zufall,
weil,
weil ich ein Video gemacht habe,
warum ich meinen Job,
irgendwie sowas,
ja,
ich glaube dieses Video,
könnte das gewesen sein,
und daraufhin hat mich ein Ex-Kollege angerufen,
und hat gesagt,
Max,
ich habe ein Video von dir gesehen,
du hast gesagt,
du suchst einen Job,
wir suchen aktuell bei jemand,
wir suchen jemand aktuell bei uns,
der vom Profil ja genau passt,
und ich habe mir das auch angeguckt,
das hat wirklich enorm gut gepasst,
was die gesagt haben,
was die gesucht haben,
die haben jemand mit langjähriger Linux Erfahrung gesucht,
es hat wirklich,
ich kann euch die Stellanzeige jetzt nicht zeigen,
es hat wirklich mega gut gepasst,
also die hatten wirklich Glück,
und ich auch,
und das ging ja auch total schnell mit der Bewerbung,
weil ich meine,
ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen,
ich musste kündigen bis hier,
bis hier musste ich kündigen,
also realistisch betrachtet halt da,
realistisch,
hier ist keiner mehr da gewesen,
aber realistisch betrachtet,
bis dahin,
bis zum 12.,
man sieht die Karte nicht,
29.12.2022,
musste ich kündigen,
und ich habe mich ja woanders beworben davor,
da habe ich ja auch ein Video drüber gemacht,
und ich hatte von denen,
und das war wirklich,
das war sehr, sehr knapp alles,
und ich hatte den anderen schon zugesagt,
und die haben mir schon einen Vertrag,
die haben schon den Vertrag losgeschickt,
der war schon in der Post,
und ich war dann irgendwie am,
keine Ahnung,
ich war dann in Frankfurt,
nachdem ich mit meinem Kollege telefoniert habe,
das ging alles mega schnell,
also sein Chef hat mich angerufen,
da war ich gerade Weihnachtsbaum kaufen,
im Bauhaus,
das war wirklich,
war echt richtig zackig alles,
und schnell ging das,
naja, zumindest,
habe ich dann die Bewerbung noch reingeschickt,
das musste halt der Form halber sein,
wir hatten ein Vorstellungsgespräch,
eine Woche später gehabt,
ich habe auch gleich gesagt,
dass ich nur Teilzeit arbeiten kann,
und dann war ich glaube ich,
ich sag jetzt mal so,
ich war am 15. oder so da,
sowas würde mich misstrauisch machen,
was denn,
was würde mich misstrauisch machen,
dass jemand Weihnachtsbäume kauft,
oder,
oder was,
na zumindest,
war ich dann da,
wir waren uns quasi direkt im Vorstellungsgespräch,
wenn die Leute sich so schnell melden,
warum wirst du da misstrauisch,
doch gut wenn die sich schnell melden,
ich kenne doch jemanden der da arbeitet,
das war doch alles noch,
da wundert es mich nicht,
der hat das direkt weitergeleitet und gut ist,
zumindest ich war,
ich sag mal am 15. da oder so,
da waren wir uns einig,
die haben mir eine vorläufige Zusage geschickt,
und ich habe dann,
zwei Tage oder so vor Weihnachten,
zwei Tage vor Weihnachten habe ich dann,
die endgültige Zusage bekommen,
und ich habe dann nach Weihnachten meine Kündigung abgegeben,
und den anderen noch abgesagt,
das war wirklich eine Sache von,
es hätte nicht,
zwei, drei Tage später wäre es zu spät gewesen,
das war wirklich auf den aller allerletzten Drücker,
ja und das beste ist ja,
es ist ja wirklich,
alles besser gewesen so,
vom ersten Blick als vom alten Arbeitgeber,
eine viel bessere Homeoffice Regelung,
mehr Kohle,
und mein Kollege,
mit dem ich bei dem alten Arbeitgeber,
schon viel zusammengearbeitet habe,
hat auch eine Stelle dort gefunden,
also viel besser,
hätte es eigentlich nicht sein können,
na gut,
weiß ich, ich habe immer noch kein Login mehr,
für den Account,
das ist tatsächlich ein Vorteil,
das ist das was ich eben auch gemeint habe,
wenn du schon einen Job hast,
das ist tatsächlich was,
da ist man viel entspannter,
meinst du ich würde einen Programmiert Job finden,
mit meinem GitHub Profil,
auch wenn ich es gelernt habe,
in der Richtung,
das weiß ich nicht,
ich habe mir ehrlich gesagt,
noch nicht auf der GitHub Profil drauf geguckt,
aber du bist extrem Pfeilfett,
was sowas angeht,
ich meine du hast das Archiv erstellt,
inklusive Deep Learning AI Geschichten,
zum Transkript schreiben und sowas,
das kann man durchaus ja auch als Referenz,
das kommt,
ich denke schon,
dass du was finden würdest,
kannst dich bei uns bewerben Max,
wir suchen noch Entwickler,
sogar Frontend Entwickler glaube ich,
aber ich glaube du kommst nicht aus Frankfurt,
aber du brauchst ein aktuelles Arbeitszeugnis,
das muss man ja beantragen,
naja,
Moment, Moment,
ja und nein,
du kannst ein aktuelles Arbeitszeugnis auch beantragen,
aus Gründen,
aus Gründen des Bildungskraftwechsels
und sowas in der Richtung,
so, das ist das eine,
außerdem,
es tut ja auch ein Zwischenzeugnis,
wenn es jetzt nicht 5 Jahre alt ist,
und ja,
ich habe tatsächlich,
ein Zwischenzeugnis beantragt,
und ich habe meinem Chef damals auch,
beim alten Arbeitgeber,
dabei gesagt,
das ist,
also der wusste das auch,
weil wir wurden uns ja auch nicht einig,
was Homeoffice angeht,
was Gehalt angeht
und andere Sachen in der Firma,
der wusste, dass das ist dafür,
dass ich mich woanders bewerben kann,
da habe ich auch kein Geheimnis drum gemacht,
das habe ich ihm tatsächlich gesagt,
würde ich aber so pauschal nicht unbedingt machen,
kommt darauf an,
wie sehr man sich mit seinem Chef versteht
und was das für ein Laden ist,
da ging das,
war kein Problem,
ich weiß,
ihm hat das selbst echt zu schaffen gemacht,
dass er die ganzen Leute ziehen lassen musste
und halt so gar nichts dagegen machen konnte,
weil er keine Rückendeckung von
seinem oberen Management hatte,
die waren ja alle noch auf dem Trip,
so nach dem Motto,
wir sind der geilste Arbeitgeber der Welt,
bei uns braucht keiner mehr Homeoffice
und keiner mehr Geld,
und er konnte ja auch nichts sagen,
also,
und selbst wenn es Taktik gewesen sein sollte,
letztendlich hat man ja gesehen,
wohin es führt,
glaube ich aber nicht,
also,
ich habe mal gehört,
es gibt einen Trick,
hat mir einer unserer ehemaligen externen Berater erzählt,
was man machen kann,
wenn man ein Zwischenzeugnis haben will,
und zwar,
normalerweise ist es ja so,
es braucht ja immer irgendwie einen,
ich weiß nicht,
so einen triftigen Grund,
Anlass, warum man ein Zwischenzeugnis haben will,
es kann Führungskräftewechsel sein,
es kann Abteilungswechsel sein,
oder sonst was,
und einer unserer Consulting-Leute,
oder Berater,
die wir in der alten Firma hatten,
einer der wenigen Leute,
die tatsächlich ganz nett und umgänglich waren,
und von denen ich auch das Gefühl habe,
sie haben Ahnung von dem, was sie machen,
hatten wir auch nicht viele Consultants,
hat mir einen Tipp gegeben,
und den möchte ich euch jetzt auch geben,
und zwar wie man ein Zwischenzeugnis bekommt,
ohne dass der Arbeitgeber großartig was dagegen sagen kann,
ihr müsst einfach sagen,
dass sich euer Aufgabengebiet geändert hat,
oder erweitert hat,
das ist unglaublich schwer abzulehnen,
für die Personalabteilung,
und wenn die wirklich eine Begründung haben wollten,
wenn die wirklich eine Begründung haben möchten,
in der IT ändert sich so viel,
ihr habt garantiert neues Zeug gemacht,
die letzten Jahre über,
und angeblich soll man mit diesem Grund
wirklich relativ easy durchkommen,
und sie versuchen es meistens gar nicht,
sich groß auf Diskussionen einzulassen,
sondern machen es bei der Begründung auch,
wurde mir von einem unserer Consultant Leuten so berichtet,
ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich stimmt,
aber ich finde,
es entbehrt nicht einer gewissen Logik,
würde mein Opa dazu jetzt sagen,
also es klingt schon irgendwie nachvollziehbar,
also wenn ihr sagt,
Leute, ich hätte gerne ein Zwischenzeugnis,
weil mein Aufgabenbereich hat sich geändert,
beziehungsweise erweitert in letzter Zeit,
dann kriegt ihr ein Zwischenzeugnis,
und mal ganz davon abgesehen,
legit,
das ist nicht so,
ich bin der Meinung,
die sollen sich nicht mal so anstellen,
wenn ihr schon Jahre da seid,
einfach ein Zwischenzeugnis ausstellen,
ohne zu nerven,
das gehört, finde ich, auch mit dabei,
wenn man ein gutes Verhältnis irgendwie hat,
zwischen Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmer,
und schon lange dabei ist,
dass sie das halt einfach mal machen,
ohne, dass sie gesetzlich gezwungen werden müssen dafür,
und wenn die rumkacken,
hast du als rechten Grund zu sagen,
leck mich, ja.
Zeugnis anfordern wird,
wird an vielen Fällen als Wechselabsicht interpretiert,
ja,
ja, und?
Als könnten die die Leute in der IT
jetzt mal einfach mal easy von heute auf morgen ersetzen,
die sind froh,
solange ihr nicht sagt,
ich hau jetzt wirklich ab,
aber ich glaube gar nicht mal,
es sei denn, das ist ein kleinerer Laden,
dass das so wild ist,
wenn ihr das bei der Personalabteilung,
ihr müsst ja noch nicht mal zur Personalabteilung,
ich hocke auch gerne vorm PC,
so ist es ja nicht,
hocke gefühlt mein Leben lang jeden Tag 10 Stunden vorm PC
und arbeite auch sehr gerne am PC als Sachbearbeiter,
was macht man denn so als Sachbearbeiter?
Kann mit Programmieren leider nicht,
hast du eine Idee, was man machen könnte,
wo man gutes Geld verdienen kann?
Ja, in dem Bereich, der dich interessiert,
weil nur in dem Bereich,
wirst du wirklich gut werden,
so einfach es klingt,
es macht keinen Sinn,
dich jetzt mit Programmieren zu beschäftigen,
wenn du keinen Bock drauf hast
oder mit Linux zu beschäftigen,
wenn du keinen Bock drauf hast,
das heißt nicht,
dass man es nicht ausprobieren kann
und vielleicht dann doch feststellt,
ey, es ist ja doch was für mich,
aber wenn du so gar keinen Bock drauf hast,
nee, dann such dir was in dem Bereich,
was dir gefällt und wo du dich auskennst,
weil in Bereichen, wo du keinen Bock drauf hast,
wirst du nie richtig gut werden,
und wenn du nie richtig gut wirst,
wirst du auch nie richtig gut bezahlt für werden.
So, 0815-Zeug,
Leute, jetzt ernsthaft,
0815-Zeug,
z.B. Windows Wizards weiterklicken,
da gibt es tausende,
da findest du heute auch welche,
ohne Probleme,
aber Leute,
die da ein bisschen tiefgreifende Ahnung von haben,
wird es schon deutlich schwieriger.
Zendrix?
Jo, mag ich, trinken.
Eine Frage, Herr Holger,
keine Ahnung.
Ubuntu?
Ubuntu-GUI-Zeug, keine Ahnung.
Irgendjemand wird dir jetzt wahrscheinlich raten,
benutze nicht Ubuntu,
aber es hat bestimmt seinen Grund,
warum du Ubuntu benutzt.
Probier es doch mit Mint aus,
das ist Ubuntu-based, aber deutlich angenehmer.
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Aus welchem Grund hat sich eigentlich
Windows bei privaten Nutzern mehr durchgesetzt?
Wahrscheinlich, dass es nicht so viele
Alternativen zur
damaligen
Zeit gab.
Das ist eine wirklich berechtigte Frage.
Ich meine,
die Ursprünge waren ja nicht Windows,
Windows 95 war ein großer Wurf damals.
Ich vermute mal,
dass es die Kombination war aus,
läuft auf weitverbreiteten
Plattformen.
Ja, also ich meine,
damals war es nicht klar,
dass
alles auf so einem 0815
x86-Kister läuft,
läuft auf normaler Hardware
und solche Sachen gab es
wahrscheinlich damals auch gar nicht.
Und irgendwann war halt auch die
Software-Unterstützung relativ gut,
dass es alles drauf gegeben hat.
Dann kam Windows 95,
da ging es nochmal richtig bergauf.
Also zum genauen Grund,
warum sich Windows durchgesetzt hat
gegen alles andere damals,
habe ich jetzt auch keine
so spontane Antwort.
Damals gab es viel mehr Alternativen
als heute.
Warum ist es dann Windows geworden?
Und Windows hat halt irgendwas
besser gemacht.
Und es waren vielleicht Alternativen,
die halt nicht auf normaler
x86-Hardware gelaufen sind,
weil Bill Gates so nice
abgedanzt ist auf den Release-Events.
Ey, wenn irgendjemand mal
wirklich harten Cringe braucht
und der Cringe ist zu hart,
den kann ich mir nicht im Stream
angucken, ich sag's nur,
falls da irgendjemand mal Bock hat,
Windows 3
86 Song.
Ich mach wieder aus.
Es ist das Cringigste an Werbung,
was ihr je gesehen habt im Leben.
Also wem es danach ist,
gebt euch das mal.
Es ist so krass Fremdschämen,
dass es schon Schmerzen verursacht,
wenn ich mir das jetzt hier
nicht angucken kann.
Ballmer war der Ausraster-Typ.
Ja gut, der hat ja auch heute
irgendeine Football-Mannschaft
oder sowas.
Das passt zu dem.
Ballmer ist ja auch der,
der angeblich Stühle nach Leuten
geworfen hat, die gesagt haben,
sie gehen jetzt zu Google
und haben keinen Bock mehr
auf Microsoft.
Kein Witz!
Gab es wirklich News damals dazu?
Leute haben gesagt,
keine Lust mehr auf Microsoft,
ich geh zu Google
und dann hat Ballmer
ihnen einen Stuhl hinterher geworfen.
Bitz dich, Alter!
Was du da drin haben willst,
hab ich gemacht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das sag ich ja,
aber es ging ja um ein Zwischenzeugnis,
wie du das möglichst selten
abgelehnt bekommst.
Und das hat mir damals
so ein Consulting-Typ erzählt,
dass das ein guter Tipp ist,
was ich euch eben erzählt habe.
Ballmer ist der Developers-Typ.
Developers, Developers,
das ist der Typ.
Er ist bald ruhig.
Ja, den Typ, genau.
Hast du eine Idee?
Ich würde gerne mal wieder...
Ich würde gerne mal wieder
ein paar neue Programmiertechnologien
abchecken,
aber mir fallen einfach keine Projekte ein,
was ich machen kann.
Einfach To-Do-App ist mir zu nah.
Bei mir ergibt sich das immer so
aus der Interessenslage.
Sei es Heimautomatisierung
Vor ein bisschen längerer Zeit
habe ich mich für WebAssembly
interessiert.
Wir haben einen Videoplayer gebaut.
Ergibt sich immer meistens recht spontan
aus meiner aktuellen Interessenslage.
Kann ich so pauschal dir jetzt
nichts sagen.
Okay, also wir wollen uns ja
das Video angucken.
Ich habe das jetzt ein bisschen
verschleppt.
Wir fangen nochmal von vorne an.
Ich habe schon wieder alles vergessen.
Jetzt zu deinem E-Auto.
Ich würde es mir wieder kaufen.
Ganz herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen Video von mir.
Ich möchte in diesem Video einmal kurz
ein paar Erfahrungen von der
Abschlussprüfung nochmal hervorholen.
Ein bisschen was darüber erzählen.
Also größtenteils über den
mündlichen Teil beziehungsweise die
Projektpräsentation.
Ich habe auch schon ein Video gemacht
zum schriftlichen Teil mit Themen,
dass ich da in Foren noch geschaut
habe, dass Leute da vorgeschlagen
haben, die IHK am besten verklage,
sonst irgendwas.
Das war total bescheuert.
Ich verlinke das Video mal am besten
hier und auch unten in der Beschreibung.
Würde mich interessieren, ob wirklich
irgendjemand die IHK verklagt hat.
So ein Blödsinn, was die Leute
teilweise da in Foren schreiben.
Das ist echt komplett Banane.
Blöde Hyper-PP-Ger.
Ich hatte so halb ein
schlimmes Gefühl gehabt.
Aber ich habe vorher wirklich ganz
in Ordnung eigentlich gelernt.
Da kam tatsächlich dran,
dass ich eigentlich so dachte,
das dürfte wohl geklappt haben.
Das fing erst mal damit an,
dass ich am 1.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja ein bisschen
das blöde Gefühl gehabt,
als er von seiner Abschlussprüfung
berichtet hat.
So ein bisschen das blöde Gefühl
gehabt, als er gesagt hat,
die Programmieraufgabe habe ich
ausgelassen, alles andere habe ich
auch geskippt und so.
Wer macht denn sowas?
6. Noten standen noch gar nicht
fest, auch nicht vorläufig.
Nicht am 1.6., sondern zum 1.6.
dann die Einladung bekommen habe.
Oh, okay, das muss ich ja wohl
bestanden haben, weil sonst schicken
die ja keine Einladung raus.
Ja, klingt logisch.
Der Lehrer, der auch Prüfer ist,
so halb oder irgendwas da mit der IHK
zu schaffen, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Der wusste auch auf jeden Fall
immer mehr als alle anderen.
Ganz komisch.
Richtiger Six-Header,
der nicht so pfeifert.
Dass dann mit der Neuordnung doch
erstmal alle eingeladen werden und
dann später noch ein Brief dazu
kommt, dass man dann eventuell noch
eine Ergänzungsprüfung machen
müsste oder so.
Geile IHK-Logik, wir laden einfach
alle Leute ein, selbst die die
schriftliche Prüfung nicht
bestanden haben.
Äh, what?
Gab es bei mir nicht, also von
daher alles gut.
Ich habe das schon fertig gemacht
und abgeschickt, dann fällt mir
dann während ich an der
Präsentation arbeite auf.
Chat, habe ich euch eigentlich
schon erzählt, dass wenn ihr einen
Prime-Account habt, dass ihr
kostenlos einmal im Monat einen
Streamer eurer Wahl unterstützen
könnt? Und selbst wenn ich das
nicht bin, lasst ihn am besten
nicht verfallen.
So, weiter.
Ach Mist, zwei eigentlich wichtige
Punkte, nämlich Migration.
Und das hat auch am Ende alles
gepasst. Also ich glaube, man kann
kein Projekt machen oder in die
Dokumente zuschreiben, ohne dass
es am Ende Sinn ergibt.
Leon, das stimmt nicht, habe ich
vorgelesen. Du warst anscheinend
kurz afk. Ich habe es vorgelesen.
Ich habe es ein paar Minuten später
gesehen, aber ich habe es
vorgelesen. Nekorok, da bist du
wieder am Start. Moin.
Exzellent Subscription, danke für
den Sub.
Das hatten mir die Prüfer am Ende
geholfen. Das macht ja am Ende
alles Sinn, von daher alles gut.
Ist ja auch sonst nicht umsetzbar.
Ein Malheur, ich dummerchen hier.
Jetzt konnte ich ihm gerade nicht
folgen, aber...
Ah, er hat was vergessen bei seiner
Doku reinzuschreiben.
Ja, solange man da jetzt nicht so
sehr drauf rumreitet, ist das,
denke ich, nicht so wild.
Zeidewix, Dankeschön für die zwei
Gifted Subs. Wir hatten Glück.
Tjoik und Trion.
Alle anderen haben nice gedodged.
Eats dodged.
Die Präsentation dann zweimal
halten sollten, für zwei verschiedene
Fächer, bei zwei verschiedenen
Lehrern, einfach nur mal ein Gefühl
dafür zu bekommen, wie das ist, das
auch vorzutragen.
Habe ich, glaube ich, auch in der
Berufsschule gemacht, mal die
Präsentation geübt. Also, wer es
nicht weiß, ich sage es mal kurz,
ich habe ein VPN gebaut als
Abschlussprojekt. Ich habe das
natürlich ein bisschen, ja, ein
bisschen großspuriger verkauft,
aber mein Abschlussprojekt hieß
irgendwie sowas sinngemäß wie
Standortkopplung oder transparente
Standortkopplung per Layer 2 VPN
oder irgendwie sowas, hieß das,
glaube ich. Ja, und was ich im
Endeffekt gemacht habe, ist
folgendes. Ich habe mir drei, vier
verschiedene, und das ist halt das,
wo die IHK unglaublich draufsteht.
Ich habe mir drei bis vier
verschiedene VPN-Technologien
ausgesucht. Nein, ich meine damit
nicht sowas wie NordVPN, sondern
was, was man selbst aufsetzt und
seine Standorte damit verbindet.
Ich habe mir rausgesucht damals
OpenVPN oder das IPsec, was
eingebaut war. Was auch immer, am
Ende hat OpenVPN gewonnen, das
wusste ich aber von Anfang an.
Und was ich im Endeffekt gemacht
habe, ist, ich habe einen Layer
2, also einen, ist es ein Tunnel
oder ein Tab-Tunnel, ich glaube
ein Tab-Tunnel ist es, aufgebaut
mit OpenVPN, habe auf der anderen
Seite DHCP, eine IP und komme zur
Telefonanlage. So als wäre es,
als wäre es in dem Netz. Fertig.
Mehr habe ich im Endeffekt nicht
gemacht, aber da sieht man auch
schon, man muss nichts wahnsinnig
Komplexes machen. Das ist gar nicht
notwendig für die Abschlussprüfung.
Für die Abschlussprüfung ist wichtig,
dass man sich so an diese IHK-
Geschichten hält. So nach dem Motto,
man stellt, also man reicht nichts
ein, was komplett feststeht, sondern
man reicht ein Abschlussprojekt ein,
was quasi in gewisser Weise
verbindet. So nach dem Motto, man
sagt, man möchte ein Layer, man
möchte zwei Standorte verbinden.
So, das ist die Aufgabe und dann
sucht man sich die Technologie
raus, welche sich dafür eignet.
Da kann man der IHK nämlich gleich
zeigen, oh guck mal da, der hat eine
Produktanalyse und Auswahl gemacht.
Ah, guck mal da, der hat ausgerechnet
wie viel das kostet und auf so einen
Scheiß steht die IHK halt. WireGuard
gab es damals, als ich meine
Ausbildung gemacht habe, noch nicht.
Sonst hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch
gesagt, dass man laut der IHK ein
halber Kaufmann ist als Physi. Aber
es ist so und man hat im Prinzip ja
auch keine Chance. Es macht keinen
Sinn, es absichtlich aus seiner Sicht
gut zu machen, aber die IHK findet es
dann scheiße, nachdem eh kein Hahn
mehr nach der Note kräht. Macht es
auf Nummer sicher und sackt die
Ausbildung, den Abschluss ein und
fertig. Danach könnt ihr scheißen auf
die IHK. Die wollten noch eine Note
haben als Ersatz für eine Klausur.
Ich hatte übrigens an einem
Donnerstag in einer Woche die
schriftliche Prüfung gehabt und am
Montag noch eine Klausur in der
Schule geschrieben. Da hätte ich
gesagt Schule, ihr könnt mich mal.
Und ganz davon abgesehen, die
Berufsschulnote juckt ja eh keinen.
Die taucht übrigens auch nirgendwo
auf und ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher, es kann sein, dass ich es
irgendwann zwischendurch geholt habe,
aber vielleicht habe ich es auch
verdrängt. Aber ich glaube, ich habe
mein Abschlusszeugnis, das gammelt
immer noch in der Schule. Ich habe
gesagt, das interessiert auch
einfach niemand. Gar keinen. Null.
Bleiben müssen. Aber man musste das
Zeug ja eigentlich eh lernen und ich
glaube, in der Klausur hatte ich eine
Drei gekriegt oder so. An den
Wochenenden davor waren auch Festival
gewesen. War keine ganz so gute Idee,
aber hat alles noch befasst am Ende.
Ja, man kann man kann sich wohl die
den Durchschnitt in der IHK-Prüfung
eintragen lassen. Ja, aber wer macht
das schon? Ja, hatte ich da keine
großartigen Bedenken gehabt. Und ja,
da habe ich die in der Schule so
vorgestellt. Da gab es eigentlich nicht
allzu viel zu meckern, weil ich dann
natürlich in die Präsentation auch
diese zwei... Stack Overflow Service. Oh,
das müssen wir uns angucken, aber nicht
jetzt. Jetzt gucken wir erstmal das
Video fertig. ...Teile oder zwei Sachen
eingetragen, eingebracht habe, die in
der Dokumentation nicht drin standen,
weil ich sie einfach vergessen hatte
und auch beim Korrekturlesen das
irgendwie nicht so ganz... Naja, da bin
ich, da wäre ich mir jetzt nicht so
sicher. Also, allein schon, die wollen
das sehen im Endeffekt, ob du auch
wirklich einen Abschluss hast. Gehe ich
mal von aus, ja. So wie bei meinem
Abschlusszeugnis. Also, die witzigste
Story, die ich dazu kenne, ist folgendes.
Es hat sich mal jemand bei uns
beworben, der hat angeblich ein
Mathe-Studium hinter sich. Und ich
glaube, das ist Recycle-Story. Das
habe ich euch, glaube ich, schon zehnmal
erzählt, oder? Also, soll ich es
trotzdem noch mal erzählen? Ich
sage es mal ganz kurz, also für alle,
die es noch nicht kennen. Es hat sich
mal jemand bei uns beworben, der hat
in der IT beworben auf jeden Fall.
So, und er hatte ein Mathe-Studium,
hat es in seiner Bewerbung drin
stehen, Mathe-Studium. Und dann war
er da zum Vorstellungsgespräch und
dann hat einer derjenigen, die im
Vorstellungsgespräch gesessen haben
und hat ihn gefragt, ja, in was haben
sie denn ihre Abschlussarbeit
geschrieben in Mathe? Und dann hat
der Typ irgendwie sowas erzählt wie,
ja, die, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau,
was es war, die dritte Vermutung von
sowieso, darüber habe ich meine
Abschlussarbeit geschrieben. So,
normalerweise wäre an der Stelle, ach
ja, und die Abschlussarbeit ist auch
unter Verschluss, weil die irgendwie
Betriebsgeheimnisse enthält oder
irgendwie sowas hat er erzählt. So,
zumindest der Typ hatte Pech. Ich
glaube, mehr Pech als dieser Typ
kannst du nicht haben. Normalerweise
wäre die Diskussion erledigt gewesen,
ja. Niemand, der in so einem, oder
sag mal so, kaum jemand, der in so
einem Vorstellungsgespräch sitzt, hat
Ahnung davon, was der Typ in seinem
Mathe-Studium da in seiner
Abschlussprüfung gemacht hat. Der hat
aber echt Pech gehabt. Und zwar, wir
hatten damals der Teamleiter von
unseren Java-Entwicklern damals. Der
war eigentlich nur Teamleiter von
unseren Java-Entwicklern, weil er
Geld gebraucht hat. Sorry, nicht der
Teamleiter, der Technic-Elite quasi
von unserem Java-Entwicklungszeug.
Der war aber auch nur Java-
Programmierer zu Tagzeiten, weil er
Geld gebraucht hat. Dem seine
Leidenschaft und Hobby ist es, in
irgend so einer Mathematiker-Vereinigung
oder in so einem Mathematiker-Club
sich um ungelöste mathematische
Probleme zu kümmern. Also der Typ in
dem Vorstellungsgespräch, der hatte halt
das Pech, dass der Einzige
wahrscheinlich im Umkreis von, na
okay, bestimmt nicht der Einzige, wir
haben die Uni noch in Frankfurt, aber
also er hatte wirklich Pech, dass der
Einzige in einem größeren Umkreis, der
überhaupt weiß, wovon er spricht, in
diesem Vorstellungsgespräch gesessen
hat. Und jetzt kam halt der Hit, der
Typ hat halt irgendwie gesagt, irgendwie
die dritte Vermutung von dem und dem,
hat er seine Abschlussarbeit geschrieben
und dann meinte der Typ so, dann meinte
unser Ober-Mathematiker so, ah, also die
erste und zweite Vermutung, die sagt mir
was, aber sagen sie doch mal, was war
denn jetzt nochmal die dritte, die dritte,
die dritte sagt mir gar nichts. Und dann
und das hat den Typ wohl so aus der
Fassung gebracht, der hat nichts mehr
rausgekriegt, alter, der war komplett
durch. Alter, das war, also das hat er
aber glaube ich auch nur gefragt, ganz
ehrlich, es gingen zu dem damaligen
Zeitpunkt auch schon die meisten aus,
dass da irgendwas dran gefaked ist, ja,
an dieser Abschluss, an dieser
Abschlussarbeit, dass da irgendwas nicht
ganz stimmt mit der Bewerbung und das
hat es dann wohl nochmal untermauert,
weil ich meine, jemand, der eine
Abschlussarbeit über irgendeine Theorie
geschrieben hat, der sollte ja zumindest
mal einem anderen Mathematiker grob
sagen können, ey, das ist, was das ist.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht immer
alles, jeder weiß, gibt ja da auch
tausende Spezialgebiete, aber zumindest
so ganz grob erklären, das beschäftigt
sich, was weiß ich, mit Zahlentheorie,
in dem und dem Bereich, keine Ahnung,
ja, aber das war halt nix. Der hatte auch
wirklich Pech gehabt, warum hast du den
einzigen Typ im Umkreis von Kilometern,
der weiß, was es da geht, bei dir im
Vorstellungsgespräch sitzen, der hat halt
echt gelitten gehabt.
Ok, Tag der Prüfung, jetzt wird ernst.
Also mein Tag der Prüfung, ich weiß,
wir schaffen das Video wieder, weil ich
so viel am Schwätzen bin, aber mein Tag
der Prüfung, das habe ich euch schon
erzählt, deswegen nur ganz kurz, ging so
los, dass mich die IHK angerufen hat und
gesagt hat, sie sind durchgefallen,
morgens um 8, meine Prüfung war
mittags um 14 Uhr, da habe ich gesagt,
hä, wie kann ich denn durchgefallen sein,
wenn ich meine Prüfung noch gar nicht
hatte und dann hat die IHK gesagt, ja,
sie haben ihre Abschlussdokumentation
nicht abgegeben und darauf habe ich
gesagt, natürlich habe ich meine
Abschlussdokumentation abgegeben, ich
habe sogar noch die Bestätigungs-E-Mail
von euch, dass ich sie abgegeben habe
und dann meinte die Frau von der IHK,
so, oh, können sie mir die
Bestätigungs-E-Mail noch mal schicken,
ja, und dann ist der IHK-Server
gecrashed, 5 Minuten oder so, nachdem
ich abgeloadet habe und hat natürlich
meine Sachen nicht gespeichert.
Habe ich übrigens auch ein komplettes
Video auf YouTube drüber gemacht, wo ich
das ausführlich erzähle. Das war schon
geil, Alter, die sind so unfähig.
Ist Wirtschaftsinformatik sinnvoll nach
Physik? Nö, warum? Du kannst doch einfach
arbeiten gehen und Geld verdienen. Es sei
denn, dich interessiert der theoretische
Hintergrund. Was ist, warum willst du
Wirtschaftsinformatik studieren? Also du
musst weder für einen Job noch für mehr
Gehalt Wirtschaftsinformatik studieren.
Vielleicht im Durchschnitt, ja, okay,
sicherlich ist es im Durchschnitt so,
dass Leute, Studierende mehr verdienen,
das muss aber nicht in deinem Einzelfall
so sein. Der Durchschnitt kommt halt
irgendwie zustande, aber du kannst auch
ohne Probleme als Physik gut verdienen.
Ja, na gut, dann sind wir uns ja einig,
also gehst du nicht Wirtschaftsinformatik
studieren. Das ist echt der Lahn, den kannst
du vergessen. Okay, wir müssen das Video
fertig gucken. Tag der Prüfung, okay,
jetzt geht es los, jetzt hat er seine
Prüfung, also. 6.16 Uhr, ich hatte mir
schon gedacht, dass ich einer der Letzten
oder der Letzte an dem Tag bin. Ob das
vielleicht zu meinem Vorteil ist, weiß ich
nicht, aber ich glaube, dass wir dann ja
wahrscheinlich auch jemanden, die haben
keinen Bock, die wollen heim. Ich war auch
einer der Letzten, ich war in der Börse,
war er auch in der Börse? Oh, das
interessiert mich jetzt. Ach nee, Quatsch,
der kommt ja gar nicht aus Frankfurt.
Keck. Ich bin komplett vertan, der ist
überhaupt nicht aus Frankfurt, der wird
bestimmt nicht bei der Börse seine
Abschlussprüfung haben. Übrigens, vor der
Börse habe ich dort auch gemerkt, nach
meiner Abschlussprüfung, vor der
Frankfurter Börse steht ja der Bulle
und der Bär. Dieses Bild kennt man
vielleicht aus den Nachrichten. Nur so
als kleiner Tipp, wenn ihr da eure
Abschlussprüfung machen müsst, die ist
ja im Sommer, die Abschlussprüfung, oder
ist die Sonne den ganzen Tag auf diese
Bronzestatuen gescheint? Leute, kommt
nicht auf die Idee, den Kram anzufassen.
Ich wollte ein Foto machen und habe mich
drangelehnt, so mit der Hand, nur mit der
Hand, also so drangestützt mit der Hand.
Leute, ich habe mir so die Finger
verbrannt. Ich bin da dran, also es hat
noch nicht gekokelt oder gezischt
oder so, aber das Zeug, das ist wirklich,
wenn es den ganzen Tag so ist, das ist
brutal heiß. Es war auch so gewesen, dass
ich an dem Tag, weil ich weiß, dass ich
vielleicht manchmal einen etwas
gereizteren Magen habe. Oh ja, da kann
ich mich mit identifizieren, das habe ich
auch. Habe ich auch nicht besonders viel
gegessen, also war ich dann da gewesen.
Gute Wahl, Pfeifettentscheidung.
Beim Aldi vorbeifahren, irgendwas kleines,
weiß ich nicht, habe ich nicht gemacht.
Auf dem Rückweg von der Abschlussprüfung
erst mal Fett am Hauptbahnhof
McDonald's fressen. Ich habe seit Jahren
kein McDonald's gefuttert, aber das muss
sein. Also hatte ich dann während dieser
Präsentation dort auch die ganze Zeit
Hunger gehabt, aber ich glaube, niemand
hat den knurrenden Magen gehört, weil
glaube ich nur einmal. Hast du ja eh ein
bisschen Adrenalin, also das fällt dann
gar nicht so auf, das merkt man selbst
gar nicht so groß. Ich bin, also
normalerweise brauchst du etwa eine Stunde
dahin. Da bin ich da ganz peu a peu,
irgendwie zwei Stunden vorher dann
hingefahren, habe mir dann gedacht, so
ja, falls jetzt irgendwas passiert, wenn,
falls sich einer auf dem Weg festklebt
oder einbetoniert, kann ja heute schon
mal vorkommen, dann ist man zu spät zur
Prüfung. Ich habe dann dann auch mal
einen kleinen Zeitpuffer drin, weil
die Prüfer das wahrscheinlich nicht
interessiert. Fisch, danke für den Zap.
Fünf Minuten kann man vielleicht nochmal
irgendwo gerade sein lassen, aber
ansonsten glaube ich, dass ich dann
tatsächlich nicht so viel Glück habe.
Saß ich dann noch im Auto so davor,
bin dann die Prüfung nochmal durchgegangen
auf dem Handy tausendmal, da glaube ich
noch eine kleine Änderung eingetragen
und dann bin ich dann irgendwann rein.
Das ist eine Sache, das mache ich
mittlerweile nicht mehr. Also auch wenn
ich ein Video mache oder irgendwas
vortrage, wie gesagt, ich mache es ja
mittlerweile ganz gerne im Vergleich zu
früher. Bei der neuen Arbeit hat es
ja nicht die Gelegenheit ergeben. Mal
gucken, wie das da so ist. Ich gucke mir
die Sachen auch öfters an, so ist das
nicht, aber ich mache keine Korrekturen
mehr fünf Minuten bevor es losgeht.
Ich scrolle nochmal durch, ja, und wenn
ich einen Schreibfehler finde, dann
korrigiere ich den vielleicht auch, aber
ich füge keine neuen Punkte mehr in den
Slides hinzu und solche Geschichten.
Die Räume gesucht und irgendwie
jemand anderen bei mir außer Klasse
noch gefunden, der sagte, ja, ich warte
hier gerade, die machen eine
Notenbesprechung und da habe ich den
Raum gefunden, vor mir war noch jemand
drin, der hat mir dann auch direkt
gesagt, so ja, es gibt für den Projektor
irgendwo da und da oder so einen Knopf.
Wurde, glaube ich, von Prüfling zu
Prüfling in die weitergegeben, dass man
da jetzt nicht so weiter suchen muss.
Ja, dann haben die da kurz die Noten
gesucht. Also ich habe meinen Projektor
selbst mitgebracht, noch mit VGA-Kabel.
Wir haben ihm auch schon gesagt,
GG Eats.
Dazu werde ich wahrscheinlich kein
Reaktion Video hochladen auf YouTube,
weil ich habe so viel
Random Shit gelabert.
Da dreht mein Cutter ja durch,
wenn er das schneiden muss.
Das Ganze.
Da kann ich das, das geht jetzt
nicht.
Okay, Prüfer sind dann wieder raus,
haben mir dann gesagt, ja, sie können
das schon mal aufbauen.
Habe ich dann auch gemacht.
Habe den Typen dann vor mir gefragt.
Und ja, was gab es für eine Note?
Ja, muss immer wieder kommen.
Was? Also, der kam mir jetzt nicht so
blöd vor, aber jemand anderes saß
noch mit dabei, also ein anderer
Schüler.
Der war bestimmt auch nicht blöd,
aber er hat wahrscheinlich seine
Prüfung verkackt.
Ja, die wenigsten Leute sind zu
blöd dafür, das zu schaffen.
Schaffen kann das jeder.
Die sind darauf vorbereitet und
denken, sie machen das auf einer
halben Arschbacke und sowas.
Aber schaffen kann die IHK-Prüfung
wirklich.
Mit ein bisschen Anstrengung kann
das jeder schaffen.
Das ist nicht dafür gemacht, dass
man durchfällt.
Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie
Elite-Uni, wo nur fünf Prozent
den Abschluss schaffen oder sowas.
Nee, nee, das ist dafür gemacht,
dass man es schafft.
Der Prüfling, was weiß ich, der
hat es ausreißen können, war aber
nicht der Fall gewesen.
Tut mir sehr leid für dich.
Es ist mit Sicherheit nicht schön,
in einem halben Jahr da nochmal
antanzen zu müssen.
Dann habe ich den Laptop da so
aufgebaut.
Irgendwo habe ich es doch hierhin
gepackt mit Sicherheit, oder?
Ja, genau.
Den Laptop, den ich mitgebracht
habe, der hat einen HDMI-Anschluss
gehabt.
Hat er auch immer noch.
30 Jahre noch irgendwie
einen VGA.
Ich habe gar keinen Präsenter
gehabt.
Also das war sehr oldschool noch.
Wisst ihr, was ich hatte?
Ich habe auf dem Notebook weiter
geklickt und ich hatte einen
Zeigestab noch, um Dinge auf der
Leinwand zu zeigen.
Müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Zeigestab.
Ich hatte keinen Präsenter und
Laserpointer.
Was ist Physi-
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration?
Oder eigentlich heißt es
Fachinformatiker
Fachrichtung Systemintegration.
Ganz korrekt, oder?
So zugeschickt.
Den habe ich jetzt tatsächlich
benutzt in der Schule.
Na komm, lass mich kurz mit dem
Laser spielen.
Ja, dankeschön.
In der Schule hatten wir da auch
immer so einen Präsenter gehabt.
Ja, das ist irgendein Teil von
Logitech gewesen.
Und dann habe ich den
ja, das ist irgendein Teil von
Logitech gewesen oder so.
Hätte man mit Sicherheit auch mit
der Maus machen können.
Aber ja, ich habe das dann so
aufgebaut. Alles schön.
So, jetzt geht es hier gleich
richtig ab.
Noch eben kurz was getrunken.
Dann kamen die rein.
Ja, erst einmal herzlich
willkommen zur Prüfung.
Geht es Ihnen gesundheitlich gut?
Sie können jetzt gerne einen Schluck
trinken. Machen wir alles hier ganz
in Ruhe.
Müssen die das fragen, ob es einem
gesundheitlich gut geht?
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob
die mich das auch gefragt haben.
Die haben wahrscheinlich schon
damit gerechnet, nachdem sie mir
morgens um acht gesagt haben,
dass ich durchgefallen bin, dass
es mir gesundheitlich wohl nicht
so gut geht.
Nach dem Schock.
Aber es hat mich ehrlich gesagt,
ehrlich gesagt, gar nicht so sehr,
gar nicht so sehr geschockt.
Das Gute war, ich hatte einen
riesen Vorteil.
Die haben meine Prüfung bis dahin
gar nicht gesehen und mussten es
trotzdem machen, weil es ja die
Schuld von der IHK war mit, dass
sie meine Prüfung verschlampt haben.
Verschlammt ist das falsche Wort.
Dass die IHK meine Prüfung
verloren hat.
Oder meine, mein Abschlussprojekt
Doku verloren hat.
Da konnte ich ja nichts für.
Und dementsprechend habe ich
und dementsprechend haben die
meine, mein Projekt zum ersten
Mal dort gesehen.
Ich habe es denen auch noch mal
ausgedruckt und mitgebracht.
Also vielleicht waren sie deswegen
bei mir auch nicht so streng.
Weiß nicht.
Sie können anfangen, wenn sie
bereit sind.
Und da habe ich dann angefangen,
so vorgetragen.
Zeitlich war ich auf jeden Fall
im Rahmen gewesen, würde ich jetzt
sagen.
Ich glaube, was hat man für Zeit?
Viertelstunde, gell?
15 Minuten.
15 Minuten für die Präsi,
für die Präsi und danach irgendwie
nochmal Viertelstunde Gespräch
oder sowas.
Da ist ja immer so ein Timer mit
dabei.
Aber wenn man die Präsentation
startet, fängt der Timer ja direkt
an.
Lass es vielleicht eine Minute
plus oder minus gewesen sein.
Ich hatte irgendwie bei den
Vorstellungen in der Schule immer
zu viel erzählt.
Ganz komisch, weiß ich nicht.
Aber ja, das hat irgendwo gepasst.
Zur Präsentation an sich würde ich
gerne noch sagen, dass ich
überraschend frei gesprochen habe.
Das hatte man mir in der Schule
dann auch noch gesagt.
Und eigentlich war es eher bei
Präsentationen so vorher so
gewesen, dass es immer Gruppen
Arbeiten gewesen sind.
Zumindest kannte ich das so.
So irgendwelchen Sachen, die mich
eigentlich gar nicht interessiert
haben.
Ich hab das in der Schule gern
gemacht, die Sachen präsentieren
teilweise.
Also in der Berufsschule.
Das war so.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit nichts
gemacht.
Und wenn du was präsentiert hast,
hast du automatisch meist eine
gute Note gekriegt.
Dass ich das irgendwie so
vortragen musste und dann
wie man das so aufteilt, wer was
sagt oder so.
Aber da wusste ich.
Also ja gut.
Ich habe das Projekt ja selber
gemacht.
Also weiß ich es auch so passend
im Kopf.
Ja, das hat mich echt überrascht.
Ich habe relativ wenig tatsächlich.
Also natürlich mal auf ein
Laptop-Display geschaut.
Da waren ja auch ein paar Notizen,
irgendwas, was ich erzählen
wollte.
Aber ich habe den auch so ein
bisschen in die Augen geschaut.
Vielleicht fanden die das auch ganz
in Ordnung, weil ich so was
eigentlich sonst nicht gemacht
habe.
Ja gut.
In der Ausbildung vielleicht ein
oder zweimal.
Stimmt, da fällt mir noch eine
Story ein.
Dieser eine Lehrer, der immer mehr
wusste als alle anderen von der
IHK.
Ich glaube, ihm hilft das auch
indirekt, dass er
YouTube-Videos macht.
Und ich glaube auf die gleiche Art
und Weise, wie mir das auch
für Präsentationen
damals und heute hilft, dass ich
YouTube-Videos mache.
Auf eine recht subtile Art,
nämlich dass man
sich manche Redewendung einfach
merkt.
Es ist nicht so sehr, dass ein
YouTube-Videos dafür trainieren,
jetzt vor 100 Leuten eine
Präsentation zu halten.
Nein, das wirklich nicht.
Das ist ja ganz unterschiedlich.
Das ist ja ganz was anderes, ob man
jetzt vor einer Gruppe Leute steht
oder ob man in der Kamera redet.
Aber wofür das
wirklich hilft, ist so dieses
Du redest und du musst kurz
überlegen, wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Und viele werden ultra nervös.
So nach dem Motto, du hast
jetzt ein Thema und willst jetzt
weiß, du musst jetzt überleiten
zu einem weiteren Punkt und es
hängt kurz im Kopf.
Was übrigens ganz normal ist,
wenn es nicht ab und zu mal kurz
hängt im Kopf, dann hast du
deinen Text auswendig gelernt und
ratterst den leblos runter.
Das ist auch blöd, aber es
ist manchmal so, du bist mit einem
Punkt fertig und du willst eine
coole Überleitung machen und nicht
einfach die Folie weiter schalten
und selbst auf die Folie gucken,
wie geht es jetzt weiter.
Das ist immer blöd.
Es ist immer schön, wenn man einen
Überleitungssatz hat und dann
quasi sagt, so und dann machst
du quasi auch schon auf die nächste
Folie, ohne dass da viel zu steht,
sondern es passt einfach zu dem,
was du sagst.
Und was wirklich
an Youtube-Videos
oder generell, man setzt
sich einfach hin und schwätzt ein paar Stunden
mit Leuten, was wirklich was bringt
für Präsentationen ist, man hat
dieses, es hängt im Kopf
und man hat so ein paar
vier, fünf Füllwörter,
Sätze, die man auch in Videos
immer verwendet, weil auch wenn du Videos
machst, hast du nicht immer
hundertprozentig alles exakt
so, wie du dir das im Vorfeld aufgeschrieben
hast und du brauchst
immer mal ein paar Füllsätze.
Also ich sag zum
Beispiel immer extrem gerne
was in Richtung so,
was man auch und
was sag ich denn immer so? Ja, was man auch
noch dazu sagen muss.
Fällt euch vielleicht nicht auf, aber
das sag ich auch gerne. So wenn ich nicht
weiß, wie es weitergeht und ich manchmal kurz überlegen
muss, sag ich immer sowas dabei,
was natürlich auch noch ein wichtiges Thema
ist und was man
auch nicht vergessen darf, irgendwie sowas
und in dem Moment, du hast
einen Satz gesagt, es klingt sogar so,
als ist der Absicht und du hast
zwei, drei Sekunden Zeit zum
Nachdenken und du kannst eine gute Überleitung machen.
Also mit Leuten
schwätzen für ein paar Stunden,
alleine für diese
kurzen Denkpausen, Füllsätze
ist echt hilfreich.
Ansonsten bringen YouTube
Videos nicht viel für
wirklich vor Publikum reden, weil das
ist schon anders,
wenn du da sitzt,
daheim und kannst
ablesen und nebenbei
nachgucken und sowas und schneiden
und so, das kannst du ja da nicht.
Sonst irgendwas?
Da sollten wir unter IHK-Bedingungen
eine Präsentation halten. Ich hätte glaube ich
als Thema Server-Hardware.
Sehr umfangreiches Thema.
Da kann
man viel zu sagen.
Virtualisierung oder...
What?
Server-Hardware und Virtualisierung, okay.
Da kannst du schon mal 30 Vorträge
eine Stunde zu machen.
Bis du es abgedeckt hast alles.
Zusammenstellung, Installation,
irgendwie sowas gehabt und eigentlich
hätte es eine 2- werden sollen von der Präsentation.
Da wäre ich sehr zufrieden mit gewesen, aber dann
hat er gesagt, ja Philipp, hättest du nochmal 10 oder
20 Sekunden
mehr gesprochen, dann wäre es tatsächlich
eine 2- geworden, so musste ich dir eine 3
geben.
Das ist wirklich passiert.
Der Lehrer hat ihn gebatet.
Der hätte ihm auch mit 20 Sekunden
mehr eine 3 gegeben. Für den Lehrer
stand fest, dem gebe ich eine 3, mir hat es aus
diesem und diesem Grund nicht so gut gefallen.
Und dann wollte er ihn gebaten.
Könnte ich wetten.
Ja, er war vielleicht
20 Sekunden zu kurz.
Aber wenn ihm das gut gefallen hätte für
eine 2, hätte er dem eine 2 gegeben.
Der wollte ihm eine 3 geben
und wollte ihm noch so ein bisschen gebaten damit.
Gehe ich von aus.
Der hätte ihm auch bei 20 Sekunden
länger keine 2 gegeben.
Das sind keine Lehrer von der IHK, das sind Lehrer
von der Berufsschule.
Ich weiß auch, was du meinst. Das hat aber
mit der IHK tatsächlich nichts zu tun.
Und ja,
Bewertungsraster hin oder her.
Aber oftmals sind die Lehrer im Prüfungsausschuss.
Ist schon ganz oft passiert
bei dem.
Vielleicht hat mich das auch nur passend gefordert.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, die lassen garantiert
eine Uhr laufen.
Also bei der Prüfung ist es auf jeden Fall.
Läuft eine Uhr.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass
die dich abwürgen würden.
Aber es wird schon
negativ
bewertet, wenn du jetzt irgendwie
2 Minuten überziehst oder sowas.
Wenn du jetzt
14,30 redest, ist wahrscheinlich kein Problem.
Oder 14 oder 16.
Da kommt ein bisschen auf die Prüfer an.
Aber du solltest schon ungefähr gucken, dass du
in deiner Viertelstunde hinkommst.
Auf jeden Fall bin ich auch, was das angeht,
ganz zufrieden mit mir eigentlich.
Dann fing ja noch das Fachgespräch an.
Da hatten sie dann ein Thema
abgefragt, wie Faulahns, Vor- und Nachteile.
Etwas zu Zertifikaten
wollten sie wissen.
Dann hatte dieser eine Prüfer
noch gefragt, sagt ihnen die DIN-Normen
XYZ irgendwas.
Tut mir wirklich sehr leid, habe keine Ahnung.
Hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch
sagen müssen.
Strukturierte Gebäudeverkabung.
Dann ein bisschen was erzählt.
Glasfaser, Monomode und Multimode.
Da hinkt es dann bei mir. Ich habe es mir vorher
noch angeguckt, aber ich hatte es nicht
mehr im Kopf gehabt. Genauso wie bei Zertifikaten
bin ich auch einmal hängen geblieben.
Beziehungsweise auch bei Verschlüsselungen.
Wenn ich das vor mir habe, dann kann ich
es anhand dessen ganz gut erklären.
Aber wenn dann jemand
vor mir sitzt und sagt, erzähl mal,
ohne irgendwas vor sich zu haben.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Abstrakt ist oftmals schwierig.
Irgendwas noch mit Link-Aggregation.
Link-Aggregation.
Wie nennt man es?
Link-Aggregation, Trunkport
oder wie auch immer. Jeder Hersteller
nennt es ein bisschen anders.
Oder Bonding
gibt es auch noch.
Bei Cisco ist es kein Trunkport.
Trunkport ist bei Cisco ganz was anderes
als Link-Aggregation
oder Bonding-Interfaces.
Das ist leider so ein Ding, wo auch
viele Netzwerkhersteller so ein bisschen
so...
Jeder erzählt so ein bisschen was anderes.
Ein Trunkinterface
bei Cisco ist ein Interface, wo mehrere
WLANs drüber gehen. Also quasi
wo die WLAN-Tags erhalten bleiben.
Das ist ja im Prinzip der
Unterschied.
Das ist wo du mehrere Switcher
miteinander verbindest und keine Endgeräte.
Und wenn Endgeräte, dann müssen die selbst die WLANs
taggen, was die meisten Endgeräte ja
nicht machen.
WLAN-Tagging
wurde abgefragt.
Sachen zu Datenschutz,
Datensicherheit hatte ich von mir selber gesagt.
Hatte gesagt, oh danke, da haben sie mir eine schöne Vorlage
gegeben.
Das ist aber nicht schlimm.
Leute, das ist auch was, was ich sage, was für Vorstellungsgespräche
und so nicht verkehrt ist.
Manchmal
kann man durch
geschicktes
Worten oder Fragen
das
Gespräch in eine Richtung lenken,
die einem
von Vorteil ist.
Weil man das
Gespräch dann beispielsweise auf
IT-Security lenken kann. Und vielleicht
ist es ein Thema, wo man gerne was drüber erzählt und
sich besonders gut auskennt. Also macht
manchmal Sinn tatsächlich, sowas zu
sagen, dass dann die andere Seite sagt,
ach ja, zu dem Thema könnten wir auch noch was fragen.
Auf die Frage hier, wie ist
eine Prüfung aufgebaut? Besteht die aus zwei Prüfungsteilen?
Die besteht streng genommen
mittlerweile sogar aus drei Prüfungsteilen
seit ein paar Jahren.
Es gibt eine Zwischenprüfung,
so ungefähr bei der Hälfte der
Ausbildung. Also schriftliche
Zwischenprüfung, das ist meistens
in irgendeinem größeren von der
IHK gemieteten Gebäude
bei dir in der Nähe.
Dann gibt es eine Abschlussprüfung, eine schriftliche
am Ende der Ausbildung.
Das ist halt auch in so einem Gebäude,
ist quasi wie die Zwischenprüfung, nur umfangreicher.
Und dann gibt es
eine
Abschluss, eine mündliche
Abschlussprüfung, die setzt sich
zusammen aus einer Präsentation,
einem Fachgespräch
über dein Abschlussprojekt.
Also eigentlich sind es vier Sachen, wenn du
so willst sogar. Es ist die Zwischenprüfung,
es ist die schriftliche Abschlussprüfung,
es ist dein Abschlussprojekt und
es ist die Präsentation und
das Gespräch über dein Abschlussprojekt.
Das ist übrigens auch so,
das Fachgespräch sollte sich
auf dein Abschlussprojekt
beziehen. Also sprich,
wenn du jetzt
ein Abschlussprojekt machst,
zum Thema,
ich habe Ubuntu installiert,
kommt nicht auf die Idee,
das ist kein Abschlussprojekt, was genommen wird.
Und die fragen dich dann
die Norm für Feuerlöscher,
dann ist das
eigentlich streng genommen, sollte
das nicht gemacht werden in der Abschlussprüfung.
Also sollte sich um
dein Abschlussprojekt drehen.
Natürlich, IT ist so
ein breit gefächertes Feld.
Realistisch betrachtet
kannst du es irgendwie rechtfertigen,
dass du mehr oder weniger alles fragen kannst
bei einem Abschlussprojekt. Ja, zum Beispiel,
ich habe in meinem Abschlussprojekt eine VPN
Verbindung gebaut. Wenn da jetzt
einer ankommt mit irgendwelchen
Netzwerkstandards,
dann könnte ich zwar sagen, okay, das hat jetzt nichts mit VPN
zu tun, aber da sagen sie doch ja doch,
auf welchem Netzwerklayer basiert
das denn und dann gibt es denn da noch für zusätzliche
Normen. Das kann man sich irgendwie so
zurecht labern bei der IHK.
Und dann noch,
ja, Integrität, Verfügbarkeit,
nicht Authentizität, sondern
Vertraulichkeit,
habe ich auch ein-, zweimal durcheinander gebracht,
aber auch sonst beim Üben immer mal wieder.
Das wusste ich auch, aber da gab es
tatsächlich so ein-, zwei-, drei
Stellen, wo ich dann einfach nicht mehr wusste, was ich
sagen wollte oder sagen sollte,
weil ich dann immer so einen kleinen Schubs in eine Richtung
bekomme. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so ist,
dass man dann hingeht und dann einfach wie
ein Wasserfall alles runter
labert, was man weiß. Kommt darauf an, ob man
Ahnung von dem Thema hat oder nicht? Ich weiß nicht,
das kriegt ein Mensch mit Sicherheit hin, aber
ich bin da nicht-, also, ich weiß
alles, aber zum Beispiel-, Und das alles in 15 Minuten?
Nee, jeweils 15 Minuten.
War ein etwas anstrengenderes Gespräch,
aber dann habe ich sich dann bedankt, gesagt,
ja, trinken Sie mal ein-, zwei Schlücke,
gehen Sie mal eben raus, können Sie auch
Ihr Handy mitnehmen, wir besprechen uns mal eben wegen der
Not, rufen Sie gleich wieder rein,
und dann bin ich eben rausgegangen, einmal
kurz pieseln gewesen,
Hände gewaschen, weil ich war wirklich nervös gewesen,
weiß ich nicht, aber habe ich öfter schmitzige Hände,
weiß ich jetzt nicht, und genau gerade da,
das ist natürlich noch
ein bisschen extremer, dann kam noch
dieser-,
Ich muss sagen, ich habe da echt Glück bei
sowas. Früher habe ich es
gehasst, so Präsentationen zu machen,
gerade in der Schule noch. Ich konnte Tage
davor an nichts anderes denken und habe nicht richtig
geschlafen.
Ich muss aber echt sagen, also,
mittlerweile bin ich nervös,
klar, jeder ist nervös, wenn er
irgendeine Präsentation halten muss, oder
gerade wenn es
darauf ankommt, aber da habe ich
mittlerweile wirklich Glück, und zwar
ich bin nervös,
aber im Rahmen
nervös, dass es sich eigentlich
eher positiv darauf auswirkt.
Ihr kennt das vielleicht, wenn
ihr so ein bisschen unter Druck steht,
so ein bisschen, ich rede jetzt nicht von
im Panikmodus sein, wenn ihr ein bisschen
unter Druck steht, so ein bisschen
minimal, ein bisschen Adrenalin,
ein bisschen Blutdruck, ein bisschen
Anspannung und alles,
dann führt das ja erstmal dazu,
dass man
fokussierter ist,
schneller
denken kann im Endeffekt und sowas.
In dem
Maßstab ist das gut für
sowas, ja.
Aber wenn man natürlich dann in
Fuck, mir fällt überhaupt nichts mehr ein
und man steigert sich total rein und kommt
in Panikmodus, dann ist es natürlich vorbei.
Da habe ich mittlerweile echt Glück,
bei mir bleibt es
meistens so auf diesem
nervös, angespannt,
fokussiert
deswegen jetzt
Niveau.
War bei mir auch früher ganz anders.
Hat sich jetzt, hat sich so in den letzten
Jahren über
ja, mein
bisschen Übung macht es halt doch aus.
Andere, der bei mir auch in der Klasse war,
kurz vor mir gewesen ist, vorbei
hatte, dann gesagt, dass er auch bestanden hätte.
Irgendwer anderes hatte dort noch gewartet.
Ich kann mich erinnern, bei dem vor mir haben die
sich sehr viel länger Zeit gelassen,
mit der Notenbesprechung und bei mir
las es 5, 6, 7 Minuten
gewesen sein, das ging richtig schnell.
Ja, dann waren die sich einig,
dass er bestanden hat.
Ja, Herr Busch, herzlichen Glückwunsch erstmal zur bestandenen
Prüfung, hatten da noch ein bisschen was dazu
erzählt, so ja, Projektpräsentation
fanden sie
ja eigentlich wohl ganz in Ordnung, war irgendwas
mit einer 3+, gewesen auf jeden Fall.
Egal, Hauptsache bestanden.
Ja, da hat ein bisschen was gefehlt, aber
im Großen und Ganzen haben sie ja hier da gesagt.
Das Fachgespräch fanden sie eher mau,
haben mir dann aber trotzdem dafür
einen Punkt gerade noch eine 3- gegeben,
vielleicht aus Nettigkeit oder weil
Scheiß drauf, geschafft ist geschafft,
diese Prüfung juckt keiner.
Ich weiß es auch nicht,
weil ich bin das eigentlich
so. Ich kenn das, ich hab mir damals
auch überlegt, so nach dem Motto,
man kann das ja beantragen
bei der IHK, wie die
Prüfung dann bewertet wurde und
im Detail, mich hat es damals auch
aufgeregt, weil ich mir nicht vorstellen konnte, dass es
warum das so schlecht,
wie gesagt, meine schriftliche Prüfung war gar nicht
so gut. Och, das kann doch
nicht sein. Manche Sachen waren so bescheuert.
Ich würde mal wissen, was da rauskommt.
Ich hab das dann nie gemacht,
weil ganz ehrlich, wozu? Es juckt
wirklich überhaupt keinen.
Du hast das bestanden. Es ist so komplett
einfach nur
scheißegal. Du hast bestanden
und das ist das Wichtige.
Zwei Wochen später interessiert es dich auch schon
nicht mehr. So gewöhnt, also
ich hatte in der Schule einen Lehrer gehabt, der bei mir
immer, wenn es zwischen zwei Noten stand, immer knallhart
einfach die schlechtere Note genommen hat.
Weiß ich nicht, der war sehr, sehr streng
gewesen, hat auch sehr strenge Klausuren gestellt
und ja, da hab ich in dem Punkt
dann eigentlich, ist das jetzt
ein Punkt Unterschied gewesen, also ein Prozent
wirklich, aber kann man halt
besser so erzählen, sag ich jetzt mal.
Dann hat er mich eben noch gefragt,
zu der Dokumentation, weil ich da
ein, zwei Sachen vergessen hatte.
Er hat gesagt so, ja, das und das war das hier, ich weiß
nicht, wie mir das passieren konnte. Haben sie gesagt, ja,
haben sie ja in der Präsentation
dann natürlich nochmal aufgegriffen, jetzt
nicht speziell gesagt, das hätte man machen sollen,
dass man das und das in der Dokumentation
an sich, in der geschriebenen, vergessen
hat, aber. Das hätte ich, das würde ich
nicht sagen. Ich, ich würde
nie auf Fehler hinweisen, bin ich
denn bescheuert?
Das ist, das ist total pp-iger
der Tipp von den Prüfern, ich würde nie auf
Fehler hinweisen, in so einer Situation.
Das heißt nicht, dass man nie Fehler
zugeben sollte, ne, das ist,
das meine ich nicht, aber ich, ich weise
doch nicht einen Prüfungsausschuss
in meiner Präsentation
darauf hin, dass ich in meinem,
in meiner Abschlussprojektdokumentation
was vergessen hab.
Das ist ja total hängen geblieben, was die
gesagt haben. Ich bin doch nicht bescheuert,
warum soll ich das machen?
Und auch allgemein
finde ich es nicht, nicht allzu sinnvoll
auf Fehlern rumzureiten.
Ja?
Selbst, selbst
wenn man fünf Minuten vorher
sieht, oh Mist, da habe
ich mich verschrieben,
ähm,
da würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, oh es tut mir leid
und sich da irgendwie fünfmal
entschuldigen, es kommt nicht wieder vor.
Das höchste der Gefühle, ich würde ein Gag
drüber machen, so nach dem Motto,
ja das Thema ist ja so brandaktuell,
so aktuell, dass ich da oben auch schon gar nicht richtig
schreiben konnte, wie mir gerade auffällt.
Irgendein Gag, fertig, ich würde
da gar nicht groß drauf rumreiten und
sich selber schlecht machen.
Also komischer pp-iger Tipp von der IHK.
Aber bestanden auf jeden Fall.
Ich so, oh ok, geil,
endlich fertig und dann haben die mir
gesagt, ja bauen sie hier alles in Ruhe ab,
eben Licht und Beamer bitte aufmachen und die Tür schließen.
Sie waren der Letzte heute.
Total überwältigt, erleichtert stand
ich dann da, hab dann alles so in Ruhe eingepackt.
Und jetzt ist er auch erstmal zu McDonalds
fressen gegangen oder irgendwas in der Richtung,
kommt jetzt noch.
Ups.
Eben noch
meiner Mutter geschrieben und auch
meinem besten Kumpel und so, dass ich
dann eben bestanden habe. Ich bin auf einmal noch
bei der Arbeit vorbeigefahren, hab den Beamer
wieder abgeliefert und
hab auch gesagt, dass ich bestanden habe.
Und bin ich da glaube ich
so halb breit grinsend
ganz vorsichtig dann
aus dem Raum herausgetreten
durch dieses Gebäude, dann wieder nach unten durch
zum Auto, erstmal kurz
entspannt, nochmal was getrunken.
Ich hatte durch Zufall irgendwie
im Musikplayer auf dem Handy
irgendwie so ein Lied angehabt.
Ich pack den Titel mal hier hin.
Das hat voll zu der Situation gepasst,
dachte ich. Und dann bin ich da so
ganz entspannt dann weggefahren.
Was junger Mann
tot
passt zu der Situation.
Keine Ahnung,
ich kenne das Lied nicht.
Vom Titel her weiß ich jetzt ja nicht,
ob das so gut passt.
Situation gepasst, dachte ich.
Und dann bin ich da so ganz entspannt dann weggefahren.
Das war so ungefähr
der Abschluss der
Prüfung gewesen.
Wie man aber schon rausgehört hat, ja,
habe ich bestanden, alles klar, okay.
Es war auch so gewesen, dass der Prüfer mir dann
gesagt hat, so ja hier ist erstmal
eine vorläufige Prüfungsbescheinigung, kann ich dann
in der Firma vorzeigen oder so, gibt es dann später noch
per Post und schön.
Und auch das, was sie da eingetragen haben,
weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich sowas gekriegt habe, aber wahrscheinlich.
Ja, wahrscheinlich auch.
Es gibt jetzt auch die endgültigen Prüfungsergebnisse,
die man sich hier online anschauen kann.
Und von daher,
ja, ist das wohl ganz in Ordnung gewesen.
Also insgesamt eine 3 würde ich jetzt sagen.
Und es war ja so gewesen,
hatte ich ja in dem ersten Teil hier zur
Prüfung gesagt, im schriftlichen Teil hatte ich so das
Gefühl, so ja, das wird auf jeden Fall eine 3 gewesen sein.
Eventuell in einem Teil eine 4.
Und selbst wenn da eine 5 dabei ist, was ich mir
eigentlich nicht vorstellen kann, kann ich sie mit der
2 aus der Zwischenprüfung auf jeden
Fall auch ausgleichen.
Und dann hieß es eines Tages
in unserer Klassengruppe, ja, die Prüfungsergebnisse
sind online bei manchen.
Hab ich so nachgeschaut, Teil 2 und Teil 3
beim schriftlichen Teil, beides eine 2.
Ich so, ey, okay.
Wisst ihr warum? Wahrscheinlich,
weil die Aufgabe, die er nicht gemacht hat,
so kacke wieder war
von der IHK, dass sie die gestrichen
haben und aus der Prüfung genommen haben.
Weil ganz ehrlich, eine
2 mit einer komplett
nicht bearbeiteten Aufgabe
geht eigentlich
gar nicht richtig. Da darfst du ja, da müsstest du
ja alles andere 100%ig richtig haben.
Also eben kann das nicht stimmen,
aber ja, ist tatsächlich so.
Also hab ich scheinbar doch wo
ganz gut gelernt oder weiß einfach was.
Oder vielleicht hab ich auch nur Glück gehabt. Wahrscheinlich ist das ein Mix
aus den Sachen. Aber ich war
da richtig happy gewesen, weil das
natürlich auch der Indikator dafür war, ja, okay,
nächster Schritt kann jetzt kommen. Ich kann dann wirklich
ganz in Ruhe die mündliche
Abschnittprüfung quasi
durchführen und alles ist in Ordnung.
Also von daher, im Wirtschaftsteil ist es eine 3,
ja gut, aber die Hälfte davon ist
Menschenverstand.
Das hab ich mich auch lange Zeit
gefragt, ja. Mittlerweile frage ich
mich das nicht mehr, weil es mir am Arsch vorbei geht, aber ja,
das ist eine berechtigte
Frage, keine Ahnung, dieser Laden ist so kacke.
Die andere Hälfte davon ist
irgendwas... Die bilden sich ja
ein, dass andere Länder darauf neidisch sind,
unser Ausbildungs- und IHK-System,
weiß nicht, ob das wirklich der Fall ist.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass die Ausbildung schlecht ist,
ist ganz okay, aber das
ist jetzt nix, wo man jetzt super
stolz drauf sein müsste.
Ist viel
Schwachsinn dabei. Ganz
kurios ist, was man nur lernen
kann, wenn man Lust hat, so Fragen zu
Betriebsräten oder
Tarifverträgen oder so.
Ja, das ist richtiger Blödsinn,
das ist Fragen, die immer gerne...
Oder Arbeitsschutz-
Vorschriften und was die auch gerne in Abschnittprüfungen
haben ist so, ordnen sie
diese Gefahrensymbole zu und
sowas. Ja, also hier
Achtung Brandgefahr,
Achtung Säure und
so.
Ich bin ja... Also man erwartet glaube ich,
Leon, geht's ab dem 1.8.
los? Was denn? Als Physi, als AE
oder als was denn? Kaufmensch unterwegs
oder was? Aber wieder eine 2 bei...
Mülltrend! Ja, sowas ist da auch
mittlerweile drin. AE.
Ja, nice.
Ich hatte ja gedacht, so bei einigen Lösen, so
das kann doch nicht richtig sein. Ich hab's trotzdem versucht
und wahrscheinlich war's dann doch richtig. Wahrscheinlich
war's nicht richtig. Ja, K. hat den Kram gestrichen,
weil sie festgestellt hat, die Prüfungsaufgabe war kacke.
Kann durchaus sein. Also, wenn ich das überprüfe, würde ich da gerne
einmal Einsicht haben wollen,
wie das bewertet wurde. Stehen da Punkte mit
dabei oder so? Oder einfach nur, was ich geschrieben hab
und dann, ja, weiß ich
nicht mehr. Würde ich aber gerne mal
ausprobieren. Falls es interessiert,
was mein Projektthema war,
das hieß glaube ich... Übrigens, ich muss noch mal
sagen, wie beschissen diese Abschlussprüfungen überhaupt
sind. Es ist ja, es kommt ja regelmäßig
vor, dass dort ganze
Aufgabenteile rausgestrichen
werden, weil die Abschlussprüfung
zu schlecht ist von der Qualität
her. Das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Diese Abschlussprüfungen werden von Experten
erstellt, die es regelmäßig
nicht auf die Reihe bekommen, eine
konsistente Abschlussprüfung
zu erstellen, die Stand hält
einer kritischen Betrachtung.
Wo man dann feststellt,
nachdem die Prüfung geschrieben wurde,
die Prüfung war handwerklich so
schlecht gemacht, dass
man sie nicht bewerten kann. Das kommt
regelmäßig vor. Was ich
dazu sagen muss, dass das enorm
unfair ist. Für alle, die
die Prüfung schreiben.
Denn,
überlegt euch jetzt mal, nur mal so,
überlegt euch mal,
er hat die Abschlussprüfung geschrieben
und er hat die
Programmieraufgabe komplett gestrichen.
Die Programmieraufgabe ist eine der in der
Abschlussprüfung, die tatsächlich noch ein bisschen länger,
die noch mit am längsten dauert.
Jetzt überlegt euch mal, diese Aufgabe wird
gestrichen. Jemand,
der eine halbe Stunde da gesessen hat
und die Programmieraufgabe versucht hat zu lösen
und zu machen und dementsprechend
sich weniger den anderen, die dann wirklich
Punkte gegeben haben, widmen konnten,
die haben jetzt
einen Nachteil daraus.
Das kann doch eigentlich nicht sein.
Man
denkt erstmal so, ja ist doch gut, die wird für
gestrichen. Ja, im Endeffekt schon.
Aber man sieht,
so eine handwerklich schlecht
gemachte Prüfung ist unterm Strich
doch unfair.
Quatsch, Christian Pfeiffer hat doch nichts mit IHK-Abschlussprüfung
zu tun.
Um Killerspiele geht es da glücklicherweise
nicht.
Vielleicht bekommen die trotzdem Zusatzpunkte.
Nur, wenn die Aufgabe
gestrichen wird,
dann wäre es ja okay, aber das glaube ich
nicht.
Ein Exchange eines XMail-Servers
durch eine Bootware-Lösung.
Da war es dann so gewesen, dass ein Kunde gesagt hat,
ja wir haben jetzt ein paar Mitarbeiter mehr,
hier Spamfilter und so weiter läuft nicht.
Ein Exchange oder XM?
Ich habe nicht richtig zugehört.
...Bootware-Lösung.
Das hieß, glaube ich,
Austausch eines XMail-Servers.
Ein XMail-Server. Linux-Stells.
Nice.
Da war es dann so gewesen, dass ein Kunde gesagt hat,
ja wir haben jetzt ein paar Mitarbeiter mehr,
Spamfilter und so weiter läuft nicht. Die wollen auf jeden Fall was Besseres haben.
Jepp, Tux.
Dann sich da eine Gruppe irgendwie raussuchen.
Aber Exim ist auch abartig zu konfigurieren. Das habe ich vor Jahrzehnten, kann man sagen, gemacht.
Ich meine 2005, 2006 sind tatsächlich Jahrzehnte her. Das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, aber ja.
Ich unterstütze auch natürlich E-Mails und Spamfilter mit dabei. Gemeinsam Kalender, solche Sachen.
Office 365 ist natürlich immer ein bisschen teuer, deswegen zwei andere Lösungen.
Eine von denen habe ich mir dann ausgesucht und einen E-Mail-Server eingerichtet und ich habe das gemacht.
Also ich hätte mir es deutlich schwerer vorgestellt, aber das hat beim zweiten Versuch, glaube ich, direkt geklappt.
Und irgendwie Let's-Encrypt-Zertifikate da reinzusetzen, das hat ein bisschen länger gedauert.
Hatte mich auch erst gewundert, aber irgendwie ging das ein bisschen zu leicht.
Und einen Mail-Server hatte ich vorher noch nicht eingerichtet.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich einfach nur zu oft mit Mail-Servern irgendwie rumgearbeitet oder sowas.
Und ja, dann am Ende noch eine Migration. Das, was ich vergessen hatte, war, dass, weil man von POP3 auf E-Map quasi umsteigt.
Was auch eine sehr gute Idee ist. POP3 ist so wirklich outdated, overrated, jebaited mittlerweile.
Dass man dann noch irgendwie die POP3...
Gut, du brauchst mehr Speicher auf dem Mail-Server. Ja, aber ansonsten hat es nur Vorteile.
...3 Account-Postfächer mit rüberzieht.
Kannst auch viel mehr Services anbieten, ja. E-Mail-Suche und sonstige Geschichten. Das kannst du ja mit POP3 gar nicht machen.
Ja, kannst einen Outlook eigentlich machen, in dem man vom einen Postfach drag-and-drop alles ins andere reinzieht.
Und das hatte ich da irgendwie überhaupt nicht mit beachtet, weil ich irgendwie da im Hinterkopf hatte,
so dass die Migrationen einfach nur die Postfächer sind, also die Namen und die Nutzer dafür und mehr nicht.
Das war, glaube ich, das, was ich da in der Dokumentation erst nicht mit drin hatte.
Aber gut, ich schätze, ich habe genug erzählt. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was ihr dazu sagt.
Vielleicht hilft das auch dem einen oder anderen später mal, sich dann vielleicht auch die Prüfungen vorzubereiten.
Ich muss jetzt auch ins Bett gehen, Leute.
Damit man weiß, ja, okay, das und das passiert dann mal oder eben auch nicht. Wie kann das ablaufen?
Ist ganz normal, dass man nervös ist, aber dieser eine Lehrer bei uns, der immer mehr wusste als alle anderen.
Also, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob der mehr wusste, aber dann wissen wir auf jeden Fall hier in diesem Video, wen ich meine.
Der sagte auch, es ist schwierig, einen Lehrer im Rote zu kriegen. Es ist aber auch schwierig, durchzufallen.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt, da gebe ich ihm recht.
Eigentlich wollen die Prüfer einen da auch nicht komplett durchfallen lassen, aber wenn man sich da so ein bisschen veranstrengt,
so wie ich das jetzt gemacht habe, finde ich, ist das absolut okay. Das kriegt man hin.
Und zur Not, da wird dann wahrscheinlich auch niemand den Daumen abreißen. Wie heißt das?
Den Kopf abreißen, wenn man dann doch mal ein halbes Jahr länger machen muss.
Mein Chef sagte dazu dann auch nur.
Aber bei der COG-IT wird eher was anderes abgegessen, oder?
Ist ja nicht schlimm, wenn du dann noch ein halbes Jahr...
Also, wer das jetzt den Zusammenhang nicht versteht, die Firma in der IHK-Prüfung hieß COG-IT.
In jeder IHK-Prüfung steht immer drinnen, sie sind Systemadministrator in der Alligator GmbH und sowas.
Und diesmal war in der Abschlussprüfung der Firmenname COG-IT.
Wenn man sich da länger machen muss, haben wir eine billige Arbeitskraft.
Recht hat er ja, aber ich habe mir das Gegenteil bewiesen. Das ist, glaube ich, ganz in Ordnung.
Äh, ja. Ja, ja.
Ich bedanke mich dann auf jeden Fall fürs Zuschauen.
Ja, freut mich, dass er es geschafft hat.
Ihr könnt ihm ja auch mal alle noch eine Runde GG-Eats oder irgendwas unter das Video posten.
Nice. Schön, dass er es hingekriegt hat. Freut mich.
Ich hatte ja so ein bisschen, bisschen... Ups, das wollte ich jetzt gar nicht kopieren.
Ich hatte ja so ein bisschen, bisschen Bedenken, dass er das vielleicht gar zu optimistisch sieht.
Somit, ich habe da eine Aufgabe gestrichen und da nicht gemacht, aber nice, dass er es geschafft hat.
Sehr gut.
Leute, Bettgetime. Ich muss jetzt pennen.
Morgen wieder arbeiten. Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut. Bis dann. CU.